Herzlich Willkommen zu Alternativlos, die Folge 9. Mit Fefe und Frank und als Gast haben wir heute Monoxid. Abu Monoxid.
Achso ja, sein Kampfnamen.
Ich bin gerade getauft worden, hab ich festgestellt.
Tach.
Genau, Abu Monoxid arbeitet in den Medien.
TM.
Genau, in den öffentlich-rechtlichen Medien. So viel sollte da zugesagt sein.
Und wir reden heute über den ganzen Unsinn, der da gerade in den Medien passiert zum Thema Terror und greifen das mal als Gelegenheit, um über Agitationen, Propaganda und Manipulationen mit Informationen und ähnlichen Dingen zu reden, damit wir vielleicht mal euch ein bisschen helfen können, diesen ganzen Schwachsinn, der da gerade passiert, ein wenig einzuordnen und zu verstehen, weil momentan die richtigen Medien dazu ja offensichtlich nicht mehr so ganz in der Lage sind. Und da wollen wir auch darüber reden, warum es so ist und wie es soweit kommen könnte und welche Mechanismen dahinterstecken.
Eigentlich ist eine schlechte Launesendung, ne? Die Tage haben wirklich schlechte Laune gekriegt.
Ja, beim Nachrichtenlesen dieser Tage habe ich auch echt schlechte Laune gekriegt. Wie ist das bei dir? Du musst ja manchmal Nachrichten vorlesen. Kriegt man da auch schlechte Laune?
Nein, Nachrichten vorlesen muss ich glücklicherweise selber nicht.
Aber wir haben das mal beobachtet beim Chaos Radio.
Dass ich das aussehe.
Nein, nicht du, aber wie Nachrichten vorgelesen werden. Es gibt zwei interessante Aspekte daran. Das erste ist, da kommt so ein Typ rein und hat ausgedruckt die Meldung, die er dann vorliest und es ist unklar, wo das jetzt herkommt und wer das sortiert. Aber der für mich spannendere Aspekt ist, dass die Stimme von dem anders klingt, wenn man ihn außerhalb des Studios anspricht und wenn er die Nachrichten vorliest. Also es gibt so eine eigene Nachrichtenvorlese Gravitas Stimme.
Ansprechhaltung nennt man das, aber das ist...
Ansprechhaltung, genau, mach doch mal vor.
Eine Ansprechhaltung, nein, fuck mal. Oh Mann, das ist total fies, weil das ist Voreffekt. Außerdem hab ich gerade keinen Text dabei, aber um die andere Frage...
Lorem Ipsum.
Lorem Ipsum. Der 34-jährige Lorem Ipsum aus Bad Boderstedt hat gestern... Nee, ich kann das nicht. Ich bin auch tatsächlich kein Nachrichtenleser. Das muss man tatsächlich auch können.
Ach, das trainiert man?
Nee, das gibt halt Sprecherziehung. Also es gibt ja Sprecherziehung auf...
Sprecherziehung, das klingt ja böse.
Es ist aber tatsächlich, da geht es nur darum sozusagen deine akustische Verständlichkeit, akusische Verständlichkeit zu erhöhen.
Und das hast du noch nicht gehabt, wie man hören kann.
Das hab ich gehabt, aber nicht für Nachrichtensprecher. Also Nachrichtensprechen ist halt der eigene Duktus. Das musst du halt trainieren. Das kannst du nicht einfach. Also es gibt auch Leute, die können das einfach so. Man kann das auch relativ überzeugend, relativ schnell nachmachen, aber...
Moment, du liest es doch vor. Das ist doch nicht dein eigener Duktus sozusagen.
Also bei den Sendern, wo sie kein Personal mehr haben, ist es ja so, dass der Nachrichtensprecher so Nachrichten auch schreibt. Das ist ja nur bei den Luxussendern, wo halt noch richtig Personal unterwegs ist, dass es da einen Nachrichtenredakteur gibt und der Nachrichtensprecher dann andere ist.
Was ich jetzt nicht unbedingt als Luxus bezeichnen würde. Du hast tatsächlich den Effekt, dass wenn ein Typ das vorlässt, der überhaupt keinen Plan davon hat, sondern der es geschrieben kriegt, dann hast du sozusagen noch mal eine Zwischenschranke zwischen der Nachricht und dem Hörer.
Du meinst, dann ist er noch mal emotional distanzierter davon.
Genau. Ich kenne das eigentlich so, dass die, also bei den Fernsehsendern ist es zum großen Teil so, dass die Beiträge sind natürlich von Autoren, aber die Anmoderation schreibt sich der Moderator selbst oder er kriegt sie zugeliefert, arbeitet sie aber so durch.
Redigiert sie noch ein bisschen?
Naja, schreibt sie vor allen Dingen sozusagen so, dass sie von ihm kommen. Also passt sie seinem Sprechverhalten, seinem Wortlaut an. Und im Radio sozusagen, also wie ich es kenne, ich weiß nicht, wie es anders ist, da schreiben die es aber tatsächlich selber oder beziehungsweise es gibt ein Team von Leuten, die das selber schreiben und dann auch einer davon spricht es halt.
Aber du arbeitest ja mit den Leuten und schaffst die jetzt zusammen. Fühlen die sich nicht komisch dabei, wenn sie dann so einen Terror-Bullshit vorlesen müssen?
Finden die das überhaupt mit? Also das war so ein Effekt, den ich bei mir beobachtet habe. Wenn wir bei so einer Sendung sind, das muss man sich ja vorstellen, früher waren das drei Stunden, inzwischen zwei. Und immer zur halben Stunde, also zweimal während der Sendung, kommt halt so ein Typ rein und liest Nachrichten vor. Und ich sitze einen Meter von dem entfernt, und könnte dir danach nicht sagen, was ich ja gerade vorgelesen habe. Also da entwickelt sich auch so eine Distanz, dass man einfach das als Pause nimmt, von seinen eigenen Gedanken noch mal zu sortieren. Ist das für die Nachrichtensprecher genauso, dass sie eigentlich überhaupt nicht mitkriegen, was sie da vorlesen?
Nee, also was du beschreibst, ist ein ganz typischer Effekt, den du hast als jemand, der eine Radiosendung macht. Dann nimmst du ja, wenn du eine Radiosendung machst, wo du selber am Start bist und irgendwas sagst und sozusagen Inhalte bringst, dann nimmst du alles, was da passiert als Pause war, für deine Wahrnehmung. Das heißt, da wird ein Song gespielt, die Leute im Chat meckern dann immer, aber für die Leute im Studio ist es tatsächlich sozusagen ein Hey. Nachrichten ist genau dasselbe. Es hat sozusagen, ich glaube, es wäre egal, was da passiert. Also wenn du nicht nackt an einem Studio rumhampelt und dich irgendwie mit Eiswürfeln bewürfst, würdest du es nicht mitkriegen. Also ein einfacher Grund ist, du bist halt aus deinem Thema raus, du kannst dich kurz sammeln und dann hat das mit den Nachrichten, also dass das da Nachrichten sind, glaube ich, spielt nicht so die große Rolle. Es hilft natürlich, dass es ein gewohntes Ritual ist. Also da kommt rein, da kommt der Opener. Das heißt, du weißt auch, dass du gar nicht zuhören musst, bis der Closer kommt. Also das ist das Audioelement, was dir signalisiert, piep, jetzt sind die Verkehrsnachrichten zu Ende, jetzt geht es gleich wieder weiter. Das hilft natürlich alles, aber mit den Inhalten hat das glaube ich an dieser Stelle noch nicht so viel zu tun, sondern eher mit der Darbietung.
Wie ist denn das andersrum für den Nachrichtensprecher? Kriegt der dann die Sendung nicht mit oder?
Genau, der sitzt ja während der Sendung läuft an seinem Nachrichtenschreibpult, also an dem Rechner, wo er den Ticker hat und sein System, wo er die ganze Meldung rauszieht und auch schreibt. Und der muss halt zu halb fertig werden, das ist schon auch sozusagen Arbeit.
Es wäre mich aber schon spannend, dass der die Meldung selber schreibt, das hätte ich jetzt nicht gedacht.
Nein, die sind, es gibt natürlich viele Radiosender, bei denen sind die syndikalisiert. Also die bekommen die dann als fertig aufbereitete Nachrichten. Also da spricht ja nur einer und die Nachrichten werden über vier, fünf Sender gemacht. Das ist in Deutschland noch nicht so üblich wie in den USA zum Beispiel, wo die teilweise überhaupt gar keine Wortbeiträge mehr haben.
Na bei Clear Channel gab es mal diesen Bericht, dass die haben irgendwie 500 Radiostationen gehabt damals und inzwischen sind es 1000.
Und eine Nachricht. Und haben einen Nachrichtentyp gehabt, der hat halt irgendwo seine Nachrichten eingesprochen und das ging dann halt nationwide. Ja, aber der interessante Effekt ist ja, dass diese, wie die Nachrichten entstehen, die sind ja in der Regel aus dem DBA-Ticker. Also das ist ja tatsächlich die Main Source für sowas, ist ja der DBA-Ticker.
Naja, der Ticker.
Ja, aber gut, okay, manche Radiostationen haben noch mehr abonniert, aber die meisten sind doch mittlerweile runter auf DBA.
Okay, also ich hab die Ticker-Situation nicht so genau verfolgt, aber mindestens Reuters ist glaube ich noch bei.
Ah, okay, dann.
Und ich weiß gar nicht genau, irgendeine Agentur hat sich jetzt gerade vereinigt oder ist aufgegangen, aber AFP und AP gehörten auf jeden Fall früher auch zum, zumindest in größeren Redaktionen zum Standard.
Na gut, aber jedenfalls, das Ausgangsmaterial sind eben die Nachrichten-Agenturen. Und die Nachrichten-Agenturen, also wir haben uns neulich bei DPA mal angucken können, das war sehr interessant, wie so eine Nachrichten-Agentur funktioniert und wie halt auch deren Einordnung von Themenwichtigkeiten ist. So eine der krasseren Erkenntnisse da war zum Beispiel, dass die Anzahl der Redakteure, die auf einem Thema sitzen, wird natürlich von den Kunden getrieben, also von den Abnehmern der Nachrichten. Und dass so viel Boulevard in überall ist, also wenn du dir Spiegel Online zum Beispiel anguckst, dass da zur Hälfte aus Panorama besteht, was irgendwie die Anzahl der Meldungen angeht, reflektiert sich auch bei den Agenturen.
Und es ist auch nur noch Panorama, was da kommt?
Na nicht nur, aber es hat die Anzahl der Redakteure und damit auch die entsprechende Menge an Meldungsoutput pro Tag, die aus so einem Agenturstream rauskommt, wird gewichtet entsprechend dem, was die Kunden wollen. Und die Kunden wollen, also die Zeitung und die Sender und so weiter und so fort wollen mehr Boulevard haben und mehr Local News haben. Also kleinen Scheiß, als wäre irgendwie Katze vom Baum und so. Also tun sie da mehr Redakteure drauf.
Also so, dass die das Kapitalismus Angebot und Nachfahren.
Ja, also dass eben genau die Meldungen, die halt irgendeine Art von Wichtigkeit haben oder die irgendeine Art von Einordnung bedürften, die hängen dann immer weniger Leuten.
Also ich hab ja vor vielen Jahren mal einen DPA-Parser geschrieben und hab gesehen, wie dieser Feed aussieht. Also ein Stück Software, was diesen Feed rein kriegt. Und da gibt's eine Vorkategorisierung inhaltlicher Natur und von der Wichtigkeit her. Und es gibt einen Spezialflag für Eilmeldungen, die zurückgehalten werden sollen bis irgendwann. Aber das heißt, ja, aber so Größenordnungsmäßig kommen da tausende Meldungen pro Tag rein. Und wenn man sich reduziert auf die Wichtigen, also die mit der obersten Kategorie, dann sind es immer noch Dutzende. Das heißt, so eine Radio-Nachrichtenagentur, der nimmt nicht alle Meldungen, die kommen, sondern da findet noch eine Auswahl statt. Wie findet die denn statt? Nach welchen Kriterien? Nehmt ihr ja auch so was wie das ist jetzt hier um die Ecke, das nehmen wir mal rein, oder das ist in unserem Sendegebiet, das ist wichtiger?
Es gibt so klassisch, sagt man immer, so die ominöse Zielgruppe. Es gibt ja jeder Radio, sind halt eine Zielgruppe, also das Publikum, für das er sendet.
Ich glaube, wir haben keine Zielgruppe, oder?
Niemand. Doch, ihr habt auch eine Zielgruppe.
Wir haben Leute, die einen Computer haben.
Ja, naja, ihr habt Leute, die einen Computer haben, Leute, die tendenziell an einer alternativen Darstellung des Nachrichtensystems interessiert sind.
Wir haben gutverdienende Finanzstärke.
Also man hat die Vorbereitung darauf, dass wir irgendwann eine Werbung schalten.
Genau, die beste Werbung.
Wir haben sozusagen Nerdhipster als Zielgruppe.
Also Hipster finde ich jetzt abwertend.
Das war auch egal.
Du Apple-User musst jetzt den Mund aufreißen.
Du Nachbau-Apple. Egal. Wo wir stehen geblieben, Zielgruppe. Genau, das ist natürlich sozusagen, also du sendest für ein bestimmtes Gebiet. Das heißt, wenn da eine Bombe hochgeht, ist das noch eher interessant sozusagen, als ob die irgendwo in Timbuktu hochgeht. Du sendest für ein bestimmtes Alter. Das ist ja bei Radiosendern sozusagen wichtiger als bei Fernsehsendern, dass sie eine bestimmte Zielgruppe im Alter haben und...
Wobei wollen da nicht alle, die die Jugendlichen haben? Ich meine, bis an mir bis auf Plastikradio, aber eigentlich, wenn man irgendwie so Leute fragt, dann sagen die alle, ja, wir haben die unter 40-jährigen.
Natürlich. Also wenn du... Also perfekt als Programm-Schrift ist es für dich, wenn deine Leute, also gerade wenn du Privatradio bist und Werbung schaltest, ist natürlich perfekt für dich, wenn deine Zuhörer sämtlich und sonderes zwischen 14 und 35 glaube ich sind oder so was.
Und mindestens 50.000 Euro am Jahr verdient.
So sieht es aus. Aber das passiert natürlich nicht. Und es gibt bei gerade bei Fernsehsendern einen interessanten Effekt. Die wollen das natürlich auch, sind aber gleichzeitig darauf angewiesen, dass alle ihre Beiträge so verständlich sind, dass sie das Publikum, was den Großteil der Quote ausmacht, nicht verlieren. Und das bedeutet halt oft genug 50 plus.
Na gut, also öffentlich-rechtlich. Wie war das CDU-Altersdurchschnitt? Das war doch dieser berühmte Lacher von Holgi.
Ja, genau, aber es funktioniert natürlich überall. Und danach willst du auch die Nachrichten aus. Und dann gibt es natürlich Klassiker. Also wenn die Bundespolitik irgendwas sagt oder ein Minister zurücktritt, das wird halt vermeldet.
Moment, wenn die Regierung was sagt, das möchte ich ja doch ein bisschen genauer hören jetzt.
Nicht wenn die Regierung was sagt, als wenn Angela Merkel sagt, oh geil, Cori Wurst, das ist total super. Nicht unbedingt eine Meldung in der Nachrichten.
Aber wenn der Innenminister kommt und sagt Terroralarm, dann ist das eine Meldung und wird gebracht. Punkt.
Die könnte man so sagen, ja. Ja, klar.
Also das heißt also diese, was sich ja häufiger zeigt bei solchen Sachen, wie wir jetzt gerade diesen aktuellen Terroralarm haben, dass die Medien quasi gleichgeschaltet sind, also dass halt überall dasselbe gemeldet wird.
Na, es wirkt so. Also es gibt ja...
Nein, es ist tatsächlich so. Also wenn du halt da reinguckst und wie halt die Mechanismen funktionieren, mit denen diese Meldungen aufgebaut werden, also so mal die Nachrichtengrundversorgung, wo die nicht selber losgehen und recherchieren, sondern wo die einfach nur dafür sorgen, dass die alle auf demselben Stand sind. Also diese Basisversorgung. Diese Gleichschaltung funktioniert natürlich über die Agenturen. Wenn dpa das fleckt als irgendwie... Hier unser Minister hat irgendwie gesagt, irgendwie schlimmer Terror jetzt bald, aber wirklich ganz sicher.
Wie sagt man früher? Kriegsrelevant?
Genau. Dann bringen es natürlich alle, weil du kannst es dir irgendwie nicht leisten, es nicht zu bringen. Also du bist dann ja in der Pflicht, sozusagen den Gruppenkonsens mitzutragen. Und das fällt halt auch deswegen so auf, weil normalerweise ja die Nachrichtenrealität, die sich jeder so zurechtlegt, machen wir ja de facto alle, die ist ja doch relativ ausgefranst und diversifiziert. Also wir haben ja doch irgendwie eher das Phänomen, dass es nicht mehr diesen alle reden über den selben Film oder alle gucken die Tagesschau gibt, sondern halt irgendwie hat da so einen Sender und dann den hört man vielleicht oder guckt man vielleicht. Die gehört zum Beispiel nur im Taxiradio.
Na und Chaosradio natürlich. Radio Fritz hören wir alle.
Nein, nein, nein, nein.
Wir sind nicht Zielgruppe Mann.
Achso, Entschuldigung.
Ihr bist doch über 30?
Ja, wir sind Radio 1.
Du hast also was?
Klassikradio.
Ja, gut.
Brav. Deutschlandfunk.
So, aber eben genau in solchen Momenten ist es dann ja so, dass es wieder so eine Konsensmedienrealität gibt. Also nur, dass die dann halt meistens so eine Panikparanoia oder alternativlose Entscheidung stehen an Nummer. Also nur dann in solchen Momenten, wo halt irgendwie so ein Thema so groß ist, gibt es wieder zumindest für mal für einen kurzen Moment, so mal für einen Tag oder einen halben Tag oder sowas, so eine Konsensrealität, wo alle so ungefähr über dieselbe Information reden, was sonst nie passiert. Also es ist halt mittlerweile so zerfasert, dass es da eben genau nicht mehr passiert.
Also ich habe eine für mich überraschende Beobachtung gemacht, als ich hier mal mit meinem Blog angefangen habe. Also mir geht es ja schon darum, alternative Darstellungen zu suchen. Aber mein Anspruch ist, dass ich für alles eine Quelle habe und die verlinke. Und das sind immer Mainstream-Medien. Also über 90 Prozent. Und alle Sachen, die ich schreibe, waren auch im Ticker. Also es ist nicht so, dass man sagen kann, wenn man sich auf den Ticker beschränkt, bringt man nur die systemimmanente Regierungsposition. Sondern die Nachrichten sind da und sie werden auch publiziert, aber es wird ihnen eben nicht die gleiche Bandbreite eingeräumt. Also das ist so einfach, kann man sich das glaube ich nicht machen, dass man sagt, dadurch, dass es über den Ticker läuft oder das der...
Nee, aber die Einordnung im Ticker, also wie diese...
Ja, das stimmt natürlich.
Also die Vorsortierung und die Gewichtung, die da passiert, die spielt natürlich eine große Rolle dafür, welche Positionierung die dann hinterher haben. Ansonsten steht es ja natürlich als Medium sicherlich frei, halt irgendeine Nachricht, die sonst irgendwo untergeht, da wird große Drossel machen. Das ist ja das, was du im Blog de facto immer tust. Halt einfach Sachen, die sonst irgendwie in die Ritzen fallen oder unter den Tisch fallen, mal denen ein bisschen mehr Aufmerksamkeit zu geben und die ein bisschen besser einzuordnen, was die kommerziellen Medien in der Regel nicht mehr tun.
Die Frage ist auch, ob das Sinn machen würde, wenn sie das tun würden. Also du hast in den kommerziellen Medien immer ein Platzproblem. Wenn wir jetzt mal Zeitungen wegnehmen, wo das auch gilt, aber wenn du gerade Radio und Fernsehen gehst, dann hast du halt Nachrichten, die sind halt irgendwie drei Minuten oder fünf Minuten, anderthalb Minuten, je nachdem, wie formatiert dein Sender ist. Das ist ja schon schade auch eigentlich. Naja, das kommt auch drauf an, das ist ein interessanter Punkt, komme ich gleich zu. Du hast also einen bestimmten Platz und musst darin was unterbringen und willst gleichzeitig nicht, dass deine Hörer sagen so, äh, das ist passiert und das war gar nicht dabei. Also Beispiel Innenminister Terrorwarnung. Wenn der Innenminister deine Terrorwarnung rausgibt, will das eigentlich jeder wissen. Wenn du einen Radiosender hörst und das ist nicht drin, dann würdest du denken so, Entschuldigung Leute, der Innenminister Terrorwarnung, so das muss also drin sein. Und Nachrichten ist genau das. Also Radionachrichten gerade ist genau das, wo du sagst, da muss das drin sein, was dieser Minimalkonsens ist. Also sagen, wo wirklich jeder wissen muss, dass das gerade passiert. Das ist im Fall eines Jugendländern zum Beispiel auch, wenn irgendwo eine Ausbildungsmesse passiert. Das ist dann schon, das ist dann nicht per se, dass der Jugendliche dann sagen würde so, oh geil, eine Ausbildungsmesse, da hab ich schon voll drauf gewartet. Was ist mit Call of Duty? Nein, aber das dann sozusagen die Verknüpfung von Bildungsauftrag und Nachrichten, das kann man auch machen. Was die andere Sache angeht mit sozusagen, wer will das eigentlich? Achso, nee, war noch vergessen. Und Themen, die ein bisschen weitergehen, die tust du halt in den Rest des Programms. Also dafür gibt es das sogenannte Tagesprogramm. So und dann ist natürlich die Frage, wenn du Themen hast, die nicht in diesem Minimalkonsens vorkommen, die aber breiter beleuchtet werden müssten, warum gibt es nicht ausführliche halbstunden Specials mit einer alternativen Einschätzung und einer angenehmen zu hörenden Verschleunigstheorie am Ende? Ganz einfach, die Leute wollen das nicht. Das ist total finster.
Welche Leute, die höre oder die machen? Genau, die höre.
Woher weiß man das?
Das weiß man, also das Ding ist, da geht es ja natürlich schnell um Statistiken und sowas.
Also diese Media-Analyse, auf die sich dann alle berufen, ist total Bullshit, oder?
Media-Analyse möchte ich gerne auch noch thematisieren.
Also die Media-Analyse funktioniert so, zweimal im Jahr werden Leute auf Festnetzapparaten angerufen und dürfen dann sagen, welchen Radiosensorsierungen, dass das natürlich gerade als Jugendradio eher suboptimal empfunden ist.
Ich habe auch zwei Festnetzanschlüsse.
Ja genau, das ist was anderes. Aber es gibt zum Beispiel interessante Experimente, wo du dir einfach, das sind natürlich dein Stichprobe-Experimente, aber die sagen, finde ich trotzdem was aus. Du nimmst halt Leute, die sozusagen repräsentativ, was auch immer das heißen mag, aber so eine größere Kontrollgruppe von Leuten, setzt sie in einen Raum, spielt sie eine Radiobeiträge vor und die haben so einen Regler, und den, nachdem wie interessiert sie sind und sozusagen geradezu dann drehen sie sich hoch und runter.
Oh, das ist ja fies. Das ist ja wie die Gongshow, oder?
Und was du feststellst, ist, das heißt immer so, irgendwie dein Beitrag soll nicht länger als 2.30 sein. Und als Autor denkst du dir immer, du Arsch, das ist voll spannend, ich mach dir so drei Minuten oder vier und es ist richtig geil. Und du stellst fest, egal worum es geht, also ganz egal worum es geht, ab 2.30 macht der Regler so nach links so aus. Ist ja bitter. Das ist so. Der Punkt ist, da kann man dir dagegen sagen, naja gut, du hast diese repräsentative Gruppe, die interessieren sich vielleicht nicht fürs Thema, was soll denn das? Das zählt dir alles nicht. Aber der Punkt ist, und jetzt rede ich natürlich nur vom Radio. Vom Fernsehen halte ich sowieso nicht viel, aus anderen Gründen. Aber jetzt rede ich erstmal nur vom Radio. Das Radio ist die Kunst, einen Beitrag so zu machen, dass er nicht nervt, wenn du dich nicht fürs Thema interessierst und dir einen Ansatzpunkt für ein Thema gibst, wenn du dich dafür interessierst. Und das ist der schwierige Spagat. Und daher kommt es auch, dass du so Themen so verkürzt darstellst und halt nicht diese halbe Stunde hast, wo du sagst, jetzt ist es ausführlich.
Also wir haben ja unsere Hörer mal befragt, worauf die so stehen. Und die wollen eigentlich alle immer mindestens zwei Stunden.
Zwei Stunden was?
Sendung.
Ja, also wir haben explizit gefragt, wollt ihr lieber zwei kurze oder eine lange Sendung? Und überwiegende Mehrheit war, lieber lang. Nehmt euch Zeit. Und gut, wir sind jetzt kein Radio, sondern wir werden halt von Special Interest hier.
Das ist halt ein wichtiger Punkt. Es ist schon ein wichtiger Punkt, glaube ich.
Klar, klar, aber was wir sehen, ist halt eben, mit dieser Aufmerksamkeitsspanne ist ein ganz, ganz wichtiger Punkt, auf den wir noch ein bisschen rumreiten müssen, weil es vermehren sich ja die Anzeichen, dass die Aufmerksamkeitsspanne für lange Texte schrumpft. Das heißt also, dass die immer größer werdende Anzahl Leute nicht mehr in der Lage ist, sich länger auf ein Thema zu konzentrieren, sei es Text oder sei es Radio. Also das hat keine, ja, kein Wün oder auch einfach keine neurologische Fähigkeit mehr dazu da, sich mit längeren Sachen auf einen anderen zu setzen. Ich hab neulich mit Juristen geredet und die haben also die Juristenausbildung machen, die haben das ernsthafte Problem, dass viele von den Leuten, die gerne Rechtsanwalt oder so werden wollen, dafür schlicht nicht mehr geeingezäunt, weil sie nicht in der Lage sind, einen 35- oder 60-seitigen Vertrag zu lesen, zu verstehen und irgendwie im Kopf zu behalten. So deren Aufmerksamkeit tatsächlich fängt nach zwei Minuten an zu wandern. Also wir haben uns offensichtlich mit diesem Internet, zumindest einige von uns, irgendwie unser Hirn ganz schön zerwarzt dabei. Und das sind natürlich auch Sachen, die auch ausgenutzt werden. Also wenn wir zum Beispiel angucken, wie heutzutage, da kommen wir jetzt dann so ein bisschen zum Thema der Sendung eigentlich, nämlich wie funktionieren denn eigentlich so Spin- und Pressemanipulationen oder auch öffentliche Meinungsmanipulationen? Und da wird es ja genau ausgenutzt. Zum ersten Mal fiel mir das auf bei der Geschichte, wo die Zeit diesen, dieses riesige, mehrfach ausklappbare Handtuch hatte über den Leuner Skandal. Die hatten so ein, die Zeit ist ja nun schon kein kleines Blatt, und die haben so ein Sechsmal-Ausfalten des Zeitformats.
War das diese Grafik mit dem fetten Grafen und den Verflechtungen?
Wie der Leuner Skandal funktioniert. Weil sie nicht mehr in der Lage waren, das irgendwie textuell abzubilden. Also weil der Skandal so komplex geworden ist und die Verflechtungen und der Werder mit wem und wieviel und dergleichen Dinge mehr. Was einer der richtig großen, schlimmen, finsteren Skandale der Bundesrepublik ist. Und der ist so komplex geworden, dass niemand mehr in der Lage war, ihn abzubilden. Und auch sind die Skandalhaltigkeit des Materials. Man hätte da wahrscheinlich irgendwie 50 kleine oder 100 kleine Skandale daraus machen können oder müssen. Aber es war halt einfach nicht mehr möglich, es irgendwie abzubilden. Und das ist tatsächlich auch so eine Sache, die wir immer wieder sehen, jetzt gerade bei Geschichtensauereien, die passieren, dass versucht wurde, es so komplex zu machen, dass du es eben nicht mal mehr in 230 darstellen kannst. Also dass du halt dich dann, das ist schon allein der Informationsgehalt, den du in die 230 von einer Kurzmeldung oder eben von einem YouTube-Video, die ja auch die guten YouTube-Videos sind, nie länger als drei Minuten. Das ist genau derselbe Fakt. Wenn also dein Skandal so komplex ist, dass er nicht mehr in einer Aufmerksamkeitsspanne passt, bist du eigentlich schon raus. Dann kann dir eigentlich niemand mehr so richtig ans Leder flicken, weil, naja, das interessiert dann einfach irgendwann niemand mehr.
Wir sollten vielleicht noch darauf hinweisen, dass das eigentlich ein altes Phänomen ist. Also DPA und überhaupt Tickermeldungen sind so geschrieben, was ich eine super spannende Sache finde, dass du zu einem beliebigen Zeitpunkt aufhören kannst, die Meldung zu lesen und dass du alles bis dahin wichtige hast. Also der Text wird so priorisiert, wenn du nur die Schlagzeile liest, weißt du grob, worum es geht. Und je mehr du liest, desto mehr Details hast du. Aber es ist nie so, dass du irgendwie runter scrollen müsstest und am Ende sind erst die wichtigen Sachen. Sondern Tickermeldungen sind so aufgebaut, gerade für diese Aufmerksamkeitsökonomie, dass alles wichtig am Anfang ist. Was ja bei Zeitungen andersrum ist. Da ist es immer wieder so, dass der Teil, den ich zitiere, ist dann der letzte Absatz. Genau, der letzte Absatz. Und das ist schon spannend. Übrigens, was mir auch auffällt, also wo mir auch die Redakteure immer wirklich leid tun, ist, dass die die Zeitung ja aus Werbegründen, Werbemaximierungsgründen dazu übergegangen sind, ihre Storys aufzusplitten auf mehrere Webseiten. Und du musst dann unten immer auf die nächste Seite. Genau, was mich ja tierisch abnervt. Aber jetzt stell dir mal vor, du machst da die Log-Auswertung. Da kann ich dir aber mal schriftlich geben, dass irgendwie 80 Prozent der Leute nur die erste Seite angucken. Und jetzt stell dir mal vor, du bist der Typ, der diesen Satz, den Artikel geschrieben hat. Du hast da irgendwie eine Woche recherchiert. Da hätte ich auch irgendwann keinen Bock mehr, eine Woche zu recherchieren, wenn eh keiner liest so. Also das ist schon alles auch ein Kreislauf, der sich selbst verstärkt.
Aber das ist glaube ich auch ein Grund, warum es gibt ja so diese wahrgenommene Arroganz der Medien. Wir machen hier unser Zeug und ihr könnt uns alle mal schon eine Puppe schmatzen. Und das kommt zum Teil auch genau daher, denke ich, dass wenn du als Outer hingehst und so sagen guckst, wie erfolgreich deine Sachen sind, du nimmst einfach dein ganzes Portfolio und guckst mal so, okay, ich habe folgende Dinge gemacht, was sind da die besten? Und dann kommst du zum Schluss, okay, dieses, ja genau, dieses bunte irgendwie, ah, Paris Hilton Nackt-Video, hey, 50.000 irgendwas. So, da habe ich diese feine, feinausziedelte Argumentation gegen die Vorwärtszeiten-Speicherung geschrieben, zwei User. Und das Ding ist, das positioniert sich auf allen Ebenen. Du hast halt dieses Mehrboulevard, das positioniert sich in den Ebenen des Programmen-Managements, also die Leute, die den Leuten, die tatsächlich was arbeiten, sagen, was sie machen sollen. Und da, das ist dann so fest und formatiert drin, es wird auch nicht mehr hinterfragt. Und ich möchte jetzt an dieser Stelle kurz eine kleine Anekdote erzählen, die tatsächlich so passiert ist. Und zwar ging es da um einen Mitternachtsverkauf eines neuen Produkts, wo ich hingeschickt wurde, eine Reportage zu machen. Was ich auch gemacht habe.
Und sowas wie ein Harry Potter-Buch oder so was?
Oder wie ein Computerspiel? Ja, sowas. Ein bekannter großer Spielehersteller, Gnome, Elfen, ihr wisst Bescheid. Und dann sozusagen also eine Reportage machen über, da war jemand, ein Hörer mit, der hat ein Spiel gewonnen. Und der konnte dann das abholen. Ich habe die Reportage quasi gemacht im Sinne von der Junge Held. Der Hörer geht zu dem Mitternachtsverkauf, also dem Event, alles ganz launig und so. Und ist tatsächlich eines meiner erfolgreichen Stücke in der Hinsicht des Feedbacks von wegen des cooles Stück. Das konnte man sich gut anhören, weil es halt sozusagen schön produziert war und halt sozusagen launigen Überbau hatte. Es war aber 312 lang. 312 ist, wie wir wissen, länger als 230.
Haben alle abgebrochen?
Nee, nee, nee. Es gab dann eine Begegnung mit einer höher gestellten Persönlichkeit aus einem anderen Hause, die dann sagte so, ich habe heute morgen Radio gehört, fand das total spannend, stand in der Küche und hab mein Zeug hingelegt und wollte unbedingt einen Beitrag zu hören. Und ich dachte so, geil.
Für dich hab ich das gemacht.
Wenn du als Autor irgendwas erreichen möchtest, dann ist es genau dieser Effekt da. Irgendjemand hört da einen Beitrag, legt seine Sachen hin und hört sich das bis zu Ende an. Das ist auch so ein schönes Kompliment, was man manchmal kriegt. So ich bin extra im Auto sitzen geblieben, um das zu Ende zu hören. Das nächste, was die Person gesagt hat, war, das geht aber nicht. Die Leute haben noch morgens was zu tun. Das war noch länger als 2.30. Ich habe mein Gesprächspartner kurz angeguckt, weil ich dachte, er macht einen besonders subtilen Scherz. Der kriegt jetzt in die Fresse.
Hat er so gemeint?
Hat er so gemeint. Und das ist genau der Punkt. Es ist also so drin, dass es selbst ein offensichtlich positives Erlebnis overridet.
Wir haben ja wirklich den vollständig gegenteiligen Effekt. Wenn wir uns die Statistik von unseren Sendungen angucken, dann sind die Sendungen, wo wir kein spezifisches Thema haben, sondern ein bisschen vor uns hinplaudern, von einem zum anderen springen, also den Aufmerksamkeitslängen ein bisschen folgen. Die haben im Schnitt ein Drittel weniger Hörer als die Sendung, wo wir bei einem Thema bleiben, also uns ein Thema vertiefen und ein Thema eine Runde abreiten. Ich vermute, dass wir das tatsächlich mit einer Spaltung zu tun haben.
Ich muss kurz fragen, Hörer oder Downloads?
Hörer folgen mir ja nicht, wir sehen nur Downloads.
Aber wir sind relativ restriktiv bei unserer Log-Auswertung. Wir machen es nicht wie andere Sender oder Podcasts, die jeden Klick benutzen, sondern nicht nur Complete Downloads.
Die eine Frage ist, was das natürlich fördern könnte, wenn du eine Show hast, die sagt, heute setzen sich Fefe und Frank hin und wir machen mal... Dann kannst du das hören und wenn du es verpasst hast, ist es nicht so schlimm. Dann gehst du nicht extra hin, um es noch runterzuladen. Wenn du aber eine Sendung zum Thema X hast, lädst du es dir möglicherweise runter mit der Maßgabe. Das klingt interessant, das höre ich mir noch an.
Aber wir sind es auch an der Menge an Feedback. Bei den monothematischen Sendungen ist der Feedback in der Regel mehr als doppelt so viel.
Das wird wahrscheinlich höher auf der To-do-Liste landen und anscheinend sogar in dem Teil, der tatsächlich abgearbeitet wird.
Ja, tatsächlich. Ich verstehe Podcasten ja sowieso nicht, weil wir kommen nie dazu, Podcasts zu hören. Insofern ist das wahrscheinlich so ein bisschen wie wenn ich im Radio sitze, weil ich höre auch nie Radio. Aber ich kann das halt nur phenomenologisch betrachten. Aber was ich auch woanders sehe, bei textuellen Sachen zum Beispiel in meinem Blog, ist, dass es offensichtlich eine radikale Spaltung gibt zwischen den Leuten, die nur noch so auf der Oberfläche dahin skippen. Und den Leuten, die noch wissen wollen. Also das einfach, ich weiß nicht, wie sich das zahlenmäßig ausdruckt oder so, aber es scheint tatsächlich so zu sein, dass die Spaltung eben nicht mehr auf der Basis von Wissen oder Bildung ist, sondern auf der Basis von Konzentrationsfähigkeit oder Willen zur Konzentration.
Also interessanterweise entwickelt sich ja gerade so eine PR-Wissenschaft daraus, wie man unfixt, wie man also mit einem Tweet die Leute dazu bringt, dass sie draufklicken. Ja, und da gibt es so das Seminareführer. Das dominierende Muster war ja eine Weile lang The Top Ten Reasons Why, blubber. Oder die Top Five irgendwas. Also sobald eine Zahl drin ist.
Oder diese Infographics.
Nee, aber sobald eine Zahl drauf ist, haben die Leute irgendwie das Bedürfnis, die auch alle zu sehen so.
Ah, okay.
Und dann wird das nochmal auf drei Seiten aufgesplittet, weißt du. Und du fängst natürlich bei der niedrigsten an. Und so maximiert man Werbegeld. Also ich finde das deswegen interessant, weil ich glaube, dass es so ein bisschen auch selbst enforcend ist.
Also du meinst, dass die alle dann gewöhnt sind. Also dass diese Aufspaltung in Informationshäppchen eben durchaus dazu dient, halt einfach die Klickraten hoch zu treiben und damit die Werbebudgets nach oben zu treiben.
Ich glaube, dass es daher kommt. Und ich glaube, dass die Leute, die jetzt bei uns sich zwei Stunden hinsetzen, einfach genervt sind von dem Scheiß. Ja, wenn du das eine Weile lang davon penetriert wurdest, von diesem ganzen Informationshäppchen gedudelt, auch dieser Trend aus Amerika, dass sie in den Nachrichten Werbung haben und dann sagen, nach dem Werbeblock geht es weiter mit. Das gibt es ja hier inzwischen auch schon, also jetzt nicht bei Nachrichten, aber bei Talkshows, da haben sie den Gast vorher drin. Sie nehmen den Gast rein vor der Werbepause und sagen, nach der Werbung geht es weiter mit. Anfix, anfix. Also diese Idee, dass du dein Hörer ständig mit irgendwelchen Versprechen anfixen musst, damit er da bleibt, das geht mir nur noch auf die Nerven. Und deswegen präferiere ich...
Diese Fake-Höhepunkte.
Ja, auch dieser Fake-Spannungsbogen, da kommt dann ja meistens überhaupt nichts.
So N24 oder wie heißt diese andere? N24 heißt das?
Ja, und NTV, furchtbar.
Was sie da als Dokumentation verkaufen, die dann auch immer genauso darauf optimiert sind.
Das ist alles Kooperation mit discovery Channel, was ich ja furchtbar fand, weißt du, weil ich als Europäer, man hat ja immer nur gute Sachen von discovery Channel gehört vor vielen Jahren. Und wenn man das mal sieht, dann denkt man so, oh mein Gott, das ist da, oder History Channel. History Channel klingt ja, als wenn es da um Volksbildung geht, aber weit gefehlt. Da kommt nur noch irgendwie, hau drauf, kabumm, der Mann in der Wildnis, der sich von Regenwürmern ernährt und so.
Nur Scheiße.
Besonders bizarr ist dann, wenn da kommt das da, oder sind das die Sachen, die NTV kauft?
Nein, das sind die Sachen, die drüben kommen. Das ist hier, das kommt als nächstes, das haben wir hier noch nicht so. Aber so der Mann, der in die Wüste geht und zeigt, wie Survival funktioniert, indem er...
Das läuft hier auch alle.
Das gibt es hier auch schon?
Ja, ich sehe das immer noch, wenn ich gelangweilt bin, in einem Hotel rumhören und kein Internet da ist. Das Problem, also das Interessante daran ist, wenn man das dann hier sieht, die haben hier ja nicht so viele Werbeblocke wie da drüben.
Genau, dann siehst du mal diese Fake-Höherpunkte.
Diese Fake-Höherpunkte, die dann so uns nichts laufen, wo eigentlich so ein Werbeblock hätte sein müssen. Da geht es mit irgendeinem Belag, so einem Scheiß weiter.
Lustigerweise kriegen die Amis totalen Herzinfarkt, wenn sie hier Sachen gucken müssen, weil die sind halt viele Werbeblocke gewöhnt, die aber jeweils nur so unter eine Minute lang sind. Und wenn wir hier mal ein Werbeblock haben, dann ist die ja fünf Minuten und die sitzen dann hier und denken so, wie könnt ihr das aushalten? Das geht ja gar nicht. Und umgekehrt natürlich genauso. Also ich hab drüben, könnte mich da nie auf irgendwie einen Film konzentrieren.
Ich war neulich zum ersten Mal auf dem anderen Kontinent und hab da eine Fernsehsendung geguckt und so was. Und ich war nach einer Viertelstunde so enerviert davon, dass sozusagen alle fünf Minuten ein einzelner Spot kommt, was ja unglaublich ist.
Also ich mein, wenn man hier quasi Raubkopien gewöhnt ist, oder sich von DVD irgendwie die Serien oder die Filme leit und das dann mal drüben im Nicht-Pay-TV guckt, das dauert doppelt so lang, die Ausstrahlung mit Werbung, wie wenn du sie auf DVD ziehst. Und da verstehe ich auch plötzlich, wieso es drüben Markt gibt, um sich diese DVDs zu holen.
Diese Serien-DVDs.
Ja, aber wenn das wäre mir ja auch zu blöd, da 20 Wabeblöcke rauszuschneiden, weißt du, solange das nur drei sind, kann man das ja irgendwie noch machen, aber 20? So, nee, ich hätte auch keinen Bock mehr.
Also interessant ist ja, dass das ja genauso auch in der Politik funktioniert. Also dass die momentan effizienteste Strategie, wenn du irgendeinen Skandal an der Backe hast, ist Aussitzen. Das gibt also, weil der News-Cycle, wenn jetzt also mal wieder irgendeine Sau durchs Dorf getrieben wird, die jetzt nicht strategisch getrieben wird, wie jetzt gerade diese Terrorpanik, sondern die halt einfach nur so passiert.
So Sommerlochdinger.
Ja, was weiß ich, hier irgendeine Bischöffe und fährt mal wieder bei Rot über die Ampel oder so. Die hätte einfach mal, verdammt noch mal, nur zwei Wochen das Maul halten müssen und dann wäre das gewesen. Da hätte sich niemand mehr dran erinnert, weil diese Aufmerksamkeitsspannen so kurz geworden sind, auch die institutionellen Aufmerksamkeitsspannen. Also wir sehen es ja immer wieder, wenn wir den Fnord-Jahresrückblick machen. Also denken wir so, was ist alles dieses Jahr passiert?
Vor allem haben wir das selber schon wieder fast alles vergessen, weil einfach so viel Scheiße reinkommt. Also immer wenn wir anfangen, uns vorzubereiten für den Fnord-Rückblick, dann denken wir so, mein Gott, das ist alles in dem Jahr, das wissen die Leute alle noch, die werden sich totlangweilen. Und dann gucken wir die ganzen Meldungen an und denken so, Scheiße, das ist alles dieses Jahr gewesen. Und so ist das. Die Aufmerksamkeitsökonomie, das betrifft uns auch. Keine Frage. Und es ist furchtbar, man muss da echt gegenhalten.
Also ich glaube, um das mit den Medien nochmal zu sagen, ich glaube tatsächlich, dass es auch nicht Aufgabe der klassischen Medien, in der es mal sein kann, diese Aufmerksamkeitsökonomie anders zu gestalten, sondern ich glaube eher, dass da der Konsument gefragt ist, im Sinne von, er muss sich einfach darüber im Klaren sein, dass er dort nicht die ganze Wahrheit erfährt. Das ist natürlich ein Bild, das haben die Medien sehr lange von sich.
Wollen wir mal, können wir das nochmal sagen? Für das Archiv?
Nein, das wollte ich gerade sagen. Das ist ja das Bild, das die Medien sehr lange von sich auch propagiert haben, was aber auch ganz dankbar angenommen wurde, ist ja, hier erfährst du. So wie der Hund, der in diesen Grammophon...
Spiegelleser wissen mehr.
Genau, wie der Hund, der in den Grammophon-Trichter guckt, sozusagen, du brauchst nur eine Newsquelle und das ist halt tatsächlich einfach nicht so. Ich war ja selber irgendwie als Student, hab ich ja so erste Medienkontakte gehabt und war auch immer so dieser, ja, das ist alles viel zu kurz und das muss alles länger sein und da fällt noch die Perspektive und überhaupt die Medien, die Medien, die Medien, die bösen Medien und dann gehst du da rein und die größte Überraschung, die du hast, ist krass, das sind auch alles Leute, die mit Wasser kochen und das ist ein total wichtiger Punkt, den sich glaube ich viele Leute nicht klar machen und der wie gesagt auch gerne propagiert wurde jahrelang. Die Medien wissen alles, wissen sie aber nicht, sondern sozusagen was sie bestensfalls für dich sein könnten und ich vermute ich werde dieses Zitat bereuen, ist so eine Art Fefe für dich, nämlich sie...
Moment, Hilfe oder Fefe?
Fefe. Sie nehmen die Welt und präsentieren sie dir aus einem bestimmten Winkel und dieser bestimmte Winkel ist meistens sozusagen Neutralität, was nicht immer klappt, aber sozusagen...
Na das behauptet ja jeder von sich.
Genau, das behauptet jeder von sich.
Außer wir.
Und das muss...
Außer Alternativlos.
Ja, wir behaupten es nicht.
Genau, ihr bietet den einzigen Blickwinkel, was... Moment.
Wir sagen die Wahrheit, es ist nicht neutral, wir sagen einfach die Fakten.
Genau, aber ich glaube, das ist ganz wichtig. Also da muss sich mal jeder an die eigene Nase packen. So.
Das ist aber immer noch so. Also das ist kein... Das ist nicht weg, sondern jetzt hat sich das nur subtil gedreht und jetzt heißt es immer, wir sind im Gegensatz zu den Bloggern ausgebildete Journalisten und wissen, wie man das macht. Also diese Abgrenzung gibt es immer noch. Von wegen wir sind die Leute, die wissen, die geschult sind, ausgebildet sind, die das beurteilen können. Und das ist im Übrigen auch ein Manipulationsmuster, was wir noch ansprechen wollen in der Sendung, dieses, dieses Autorität darstellen.
Darüber sind wir darauf gekommen, über diese Nachrichtensprecher-Geschichte. Was ich da noch fragen wollte, um sozusagen den Bogen dann mal so ein wenig zuzumachen, war die Audioaufbereitung für die Nachrichtensprecher. Ist da noch mal so ein bisschen mehr Autoritätskompression und Bass drin?
Die Nordfrequenz?
Der Autoritätsoptimot. Was tatsächlich passiert, das finde ich ganz lustig. Deshalb kenne ich nur von dem einen Sender, das ist bestimmt nicht immer. Und das passiert auch bei manchen Moderatoren. Du hast ja eine gewisse Lautstärke, über die das kommen soll. Und egal, wie laut du sie stellst, der Typ am Mikro ist immer lauter. Keine Ahnung, warum das passiert. Aber tatsächlich gibt es keinen Nachrichten-Autoritätsoptimot. Das Einzige, wo ich das gehört habe, was man auch tatsächlich hört, ist Werbung. Werbung ist lauter.
Die tun da mehr Gain rein.
Bei uns TM nicht, aber das wird gemacht.
Weil die Leute nämlich leiser drehen, wenn Werbung kommt. Und dann ist das Hauptprogramm zu leise und wird nicht mehr mitgekriegt. Und bei der nächsten Werbung würdest du überhaupt nichts mehr mitkriegen, außer sie machen Werbung-Lauter.
Interessante Theorie.
Ja.
Also bei Fernsehen ist es auf jeden Fall so.
Also diese Gravitas-Sache, die ich anspreche, da gab es mal die erste Sendung vom Colbert Report, das ist so eine Satire-Sendung aus den USA.
So etwas fehlt uns noch in Deutschland. Warum haben wir so etwas nicht?
Na, wir haben jetzt diese Heute-Show, die versucht, so ein bisschen die Daily-Show zu imitieren.
Ja, und extra 3 und so.
Ja, aber Colbert hat dieses Experiment gemacht. Da hat er einen relativ bekannten Cien-Innen-Nachrichtenmenschen eingeladen. Und die haben dann Bullshit vorgelesen. Also so was wie irgendwie Charles Dickens, als wenn es Nachrichten wären. Und so einfach Zitate aus, oder auch Shakespeare. Und haben es versucht, wer autoritativer klingt, wie ein besserer Nachrichtsprecher. Und das ist richtig spannend, das zu sehen, wie also so eine typische Nachrichtenstimme, das ist nur vergleichbar mit diesen Film-Trailer-Stimmen, die auch sehr wiedererkennbar sind. In a world. Genau. In einer Zeit. In einem Land.
It was a dark and stormy night.
Aber es gibt so eine Spezialstimme für Nachrichtensprecher, die auch meines Erachtens dafür sorgt, dass die Leute, die ihm glauben.
Das gibt es aber nicht nur für Nachrichtensprecher, es gibt auch für Beitragssprecher, das gibt es auch für O-Ton-Over-Voicer, das kannst du beliebig machen. Also einen guten Radiomoderator gibt es so einen Speisekart, der liest dir das vor und du nicht genau anhörst, denkst du so, ah, interessant, ich sag einfach davon.
Aber diese O-Ton, die müssen immer so ein bisschen aufgeregt klingen, ne?
Ja, genau. Was ja häufig passiert ist, dass du Englisch in Deutsch übersetzt, was ein bisschen kompliziert ist, weil der englische Satz ist übersetzt im Deutschen meistens länger gesprochen als das englische Ding, aber du hast natürlich nicht mehr Zeit, um Gottes Willen. Die gute Form ist ja, dass du am Anfang und am Ende ein bisschen frei stehen lässt. Musst du sehr schnell sprechen.
Verstehe.
Das ist auch eine Sache, die in Amerika super zu beobachten ist. Da gibt es nämlich Gesetze. Wenn sie dir versuchen, zum Beispiel Medikamente oder irgendwelche juristische Sachen anzudrehen, dann müssen sie einen Disclaimer vorlesen, der relativ lang ist. Und damit es überhaupt reinpasst, machen die dann tatsächlich elektronisch irgendwie, stauchen die das auf die Hälfte der Zeit zusammen. Und es klingt dann so ein bisschen wie die Schlümpfe. Conditions may apply.
Da hab ich in Deutschland immer noch drauf gewartet.
Da warte ich auch drauf.
Das gibt es ja bei Medikamenten. Fragen Sie den Arzt oder Apotheker.
Ja, aber dann ist irgendwie so Schrift eingeblendet. Und das liest nicht noch jemand vor. Aber drüben musst du das halt auch vorlesen.
Achso, aber am Radio gibt es das ja.
Im Radio gibt es das, was erzählen die denn dann?
Genau, die riesigen Nebenwirkungen, Arzt oder Apotheker.
Ja, aber in Amerika lesen die diesen Zettel vor. Den Beipackzettel. Davon können sie Hodenkrebs kriegen, Ausfluss. Weißt du so? So richtig unappetitliche Scheiße lesen die davor. Und du fragst dich, wie kann es sein, dass irgendjemand nach dieser Werbung dieses Medikament kauft?
Was ich aber in Amerika in der Werbung noch krasser fand, waren die politischen Werbung oder in Kanada war das. Da hatten sie gerade irgendwie Wahl in British Columbia, glaube ich. Und das waren so Trailer, ich habe erst gar nicht geschneit, was die machen. Das sah so aus, als ob die irgendeine Enthüllungssendung ankündigen. Ja, dieser Typ hat eine Bank gegründet, die irgendwie über den Krott gegangen ist und ist außerdem in einen Justizkanzler verwickelt, bla, bla, bla, bla. Und irgendwann habe ich aufmerksam hingeguckt, habe festgestellt, am Ende sagen die, diese Werbung wurde gesponsert von und dann halt gegnerischer Kandidat.
Unglaublich. Inzwischen sind sie weiter, da ist es nämlich Committee 4 und der Kandidat und dann ist es so eine Stiftung.
Großartig.
Weil die Kandidaten selber, die kannst du dann verklagen, wenn sie was Falsches behaupten, aber so eine Stiftung halt nicht. Und diese Swift Boats Veterans waren zum Beispiel so das bekannteste Beispiel, die halt John Kerry irgendwie angekreidet haben. Er hatte da, er hätte in Vietnam seine Kollegen im Sumpf hinterlassen und so ein Bullshit. Also das ist auch eine Sache, die wir hier noch nicht so haben. Und ich hoffe, das kriegen wir nicht, weil es ist echt, echt widerlich.
Aber es kommt aus Amerika, es muss gut sein.
Du meinst das Komitee zur Wiedererwahl von Angela Merkel? Da steht uns noch was bevor, meinst du? So eine Sache, die wir noch mal nicht häufig genug hinweisen können, ist genau hingucken, wo kommt die Kohle für solche Leute her? Also woher kommt Geld, um Parteien oder Personen zur Wahl zu verhelfen? Das ist halt in Deutschland eine super kritische Sache. Speziell jetzt, wo wir halt anfangen, halt auch so merkwürdige Randgruppen dazu haben, die möglicherweise noch nicht im Parlament sind, wo möglicherweise noch nicht in der Partei-Spinnen-Erfassung drin sind. Da genau hinzugucken, wo das Geld herkommt, ist zum Beispiel auch so eine Aufgabe, die eigentlich ja doch die Presse erfüllen sollte. Aber da mach ich mir gerade auch nicht so viele Hoffnungen. Naja, wir wollten so ein bisschen...
Aber ist auch geil, ne? Ihr haltet von GEZ-Gewöhnen nicht so richtig viel. Vermute ich mal.
Ich halte von öffentlich-rechtlich finanzierten Rundfunk eine ganze Menge.
Also ich zahl brav meine GEZ-Gewöhnen seit vielen Jahren. Was ich nicht mag, ist die GEMA. Mit GEZ kann ich leben, aber wenn du bei YouTube bist und du gehst zu einem zufällig ausgewählten Video, dann hast du in 80% der Fälle inzwischen in diesem Video Notte Welle.
Aber ich find das schon spannend, weil du bist dann scheinbar wieder bei der Diskussion, wer will das überhaupt? Und dieses Ding sozusagen, wir bräuchten eigentlich eine Institution, die hingeht und sagt, wo kommt denn eigentlich das ganze Geld her? Das musst du natürlich bezahlen. Und das Spannende daran ist, du musst nicht bezahlen, wenn die das aufdecken. Du musst auch die 50 Fälle bezahlen, wo die irgendwas andere erschienen, da passiert nichts. Und das will einfach keiner. Das will einfach keiner mehr bezahlen. Und das kannst du heutzutage nur öffentlich machen, also öffentlich-rechtlich, wenn du das überhaupt machen willst.
Die sind da ganz bei dir. Also ich meine, öffentlich-rechtlicher Rundfunk hat seine Berechtigung. Er muss halt nur möglichst parteifern sein und nicht so, wie es momentan ist, dass irgendwie in bestimmten öffentlich-rechtlichen Sender oberhalb des bestimmten Einkommensklasse du halt irgendwie nur mit dem richtigen Parteibuch irgendwas werden kannst.
Na, wie SWR gerade?
Und das ist das eine.
Oder ZDF letztens.
Und das andere ist...
Ja, aber der SWR wird gerade komplett irgendwie...
Ja, aber ZDF ist aber auch krass.
ZDF ist gegründet worden als CDU-Sender, weil die ARD den damaligen... Ich glaube, das war unter Adenauer zu.
Aber trotzdem hat man schon geglaubt, dass man im Jahre 2000 irgendwas vielleicht da schon ein bisschen weiter ist.
Im ZDF? Ja.
Die Brenner-Nummer hat schon noch ein paar Leute geschockt, denen das schon klar war.
Na gut, also wie sagt uns nicht so sehr, aber das denke ich mal...
Diese SWR-Nummer sollten wir noch mal kurz erzählen, falls das jemand nicht mitgekriegt hat. Da ist nämlich gerade die Chefin für die Fernsehfilmproduktion beim SWR. Der Chef ist ausgetauscht worden gegen die Tochter von Schäuble. Und der vorherige Chef, seine letzte Produktion läuft gerade, heißt Alpha-07 und ist eine dystopische Zukunftsvision aus einem Big Brother-Start mit Pre-Crime und Gewinnskriegen. Genau, und mit Untergrundgruppen, die hackergetrieben sich versuchen, gegen das System zu wählen. Und der wird abgesägt und die Schäuble-Tochter kommt. Also das hat schon auch alles ein echt übeles Geschmäckchen. Wie der nicht.
Nee, also um nochmal diesen Gedanken zu vervollständigen, ist tatsächlich so, dass öffentlich-rechtliche Medien auf jeden Fall eine ganz wichtige Bedeutung haben. Nur müssen sie die A wahrnehmen und B muss dieses irgendwie Druckerkolonnen-Kasso von der GZ halt aufhören. Das sind die beiden einzigen Sachen, die wir da als Probleme haben.
Genau, und das Problem ist dann, dass sie sagen, die muss auf einer hören, damit das sozusagen... Das ist wirklich ein Problem.
Hey, solange das archiviert wird, würde mir das völlig reichen. Ich erwarte gar nicht, dass sie die fetten Einschaltquoten haben. Im Gegenteil, ich finde das schlecht, wenn die auf Einschaltquoten gucken. Ich finde, da muss es eine gewisse Grundanforderung, so einen Katalog geben einfach, wo drin steht dieses und jenes, muss für die zukünftigen Generationen zumindest im Archiv verfügbar sein. Und das muss dann alles im Internet sein, irgendwie no questions asked, in offenen Formaten, beliebig runterladbar, ohne IP-Sperre und alles so fertig.
Und wenn man sich so anguckt, was die ARD da gerade diskutiert, den letzten Primetime-Spot für Dokus durch noch eine Scheiß-Talkshow zu ersetzen, da kam einem dann doch schon so ein bisschen die Zweifel an.
Ausgerechnet mit dem Plusberg, da hatte ich ja irgendwie hart aber fair, wo ich die erste Sendung gesehen habe und dachte so, bitte was? Das ist ja noch schlimmer als Ilona Christen damals. Oh mein Gott. Und Anne Will hat gestern, oder was vorgestern, jemand diese Anne Will Sendung gesehen? Nee, ich hab nur darüber gelesen, ich hab kein Fernseher. Die erste Minute habe ich ausgehalten und dann so, warum sind die Terroristen eigentlich so hinter uns her? Und er fragt die Moderatorin so, was haben wir denen getan? Und dann kommt der Innenminister und sagt, ja, nein, das darf man nicht fragen, weil es ist ja nicht unsere Schuld, dass sie uns verfolgen. Und da wird so völlig unkritisch einfach.
Und dann hat er nicht den Maskul oder den Spiegelchefredakteur? Das ist auch so ein Punkt, wo wir noch drüber reden müssen, nämlich kognitive Dissonanz. Also du weißt eigentlich was und du tust trotzdem was ganz anderes. So weil aus diversen Gründen, wenn sich da der Chefredakteur, das ehemalige Stromgeschütz der Demokratie und das ehemalige Nachrichtenmagazin stellt und sagt, er möchte gerne die Vorratsdatenspeicherung, weil das müsste doch jetzt mal jeder einsehen, dass man die da braucht. Ich hab's nicht gesehen, ich hab's nur gelesen. Dann frag ich mich doch so, hallo, hat der schon mal was von Informantenschutz gehört? Aber nein, vermutlich nicht.
Nein, die haben, glaube ich, einfach keinen Informanten mehr.
Der Mann beim Spiegel, der jetzt der Chefredakteur ist, ist der vorherige Redakteur für Geheimdienstfragen. Der war derjenige, der die Kontakte zu den Diensten machen musste und gehalten hat für die ganzen Storys. Und wenn du dich jetzt noch fragst, warum der Spiegel jetzt so diese Terrorpanik-Nummer mit Yassin Musharbarash und wie sie alle heißen fährt, dann ist es vollkommen klar, das liegt einfach daran, dass der Mann offensichtlich zu lange mit den falschen Leuten Mittagessen war. Ich unterstelle ihm dann nicht mal, dass er da irgendwie das absichtlich tut oder so. Aber wenn du mit diesen Leuten zu tun hast, dann hörst du denen halt auch zu und dann übernimmst du halt auch deren Weltbild und dann wirst du halt unkritisch. Und fängst dann halt an, solche Terrorparolen da in die Lande zu posauen mit irgendwie einer Intensität und einer Dummheit, die also mittlerweile wird mir echt nur noch schlecht, wenn ich das lese.
Ich muss mal die Aktuelle vorlesen, weil die einfach Maßstäbe setzt. Deutschland im Visier. Terrorspur führt zum Mafiapaten in Mumbai. Was? Was ernsthaft? Das Sturm geschützte Demokratie-Terror-Parte in Mumbai?
Das ist nicht wahr, oder? Und dann kommt hinterher, nachdem sie diese Nummer gefahren haben, machen sie dann immer noch so irgendwie, ein oder zwei Tage später kommt dann noch so ein Pseudo hinterfragender Artikel, wo dann so, damit die Redakteure irgendwie noch wenigstens ihr Gewissen irgendwie einigermaßen beruhigen können oder so.
Das ist neu übrigens. Das gab es vorher nicht. Das ist ein neuer Trend, den wir aus Amerika kopiert haben.
Echt? Jedenfalls kommt dann so, fällt mir jetzt so seit einer Weile auf, kommt dann immer diese, ja, aber so richtig wissen wir es ja eigentlich doch nicht und irgendwie ist es dann alles so berechtigt, aber das ist dann so ein Detail gedruckt. Also das ist dann irgendwo ferner liefen unter Deutschland 2 oder so, ja.
Das ist Medien-Schelte, die aber es interessanterweise schafft, sich selbst auszunehmen. Also da wird dann nicht gefragt, warum hat der Spiegel eigentlich diesen Scheiß gedruckt, sondern warum haben die Medien eigentlich diesen ganzen Mist verbreitet. So die Medien im Sinne von die anderen.
Wir gehören nicht dazu.
Wir natürlich nicht. Wir haben ja nur berichtet. Es ist ja unsere Pflicht hier. Und das ist von einer Weile von der Daily Show karikiert worden in Amerika, weil es da schon lange so ist. Da gibt es so ein Cycle, das geht irgendwie damit los, das heißt, was weiß ich, irgendwas, irgendeine Quelle behauptet das und das passiert bald. Dann Terroranschlag oder sagen wir WMD im Irak. Es gibt WMD im Irak, so und so sagt es gibt WMD im Irak, der andere sagt es gibt WMD im Irak. Die Presse schreibt, es gibt WMD im Irak.
Mit Infografiken?
Genau, und dann so Presseüberblick über die anderen, die auch alle schreiben, weil die alle von mir abgeschrieben haben, aber das muss ich ja nicht verraten. Die anderen schreiben und dann ist irgendwie ein bisschen Pause, dann ja, keine WMD gefunden. Und dann, na warum hat die Presse eigentlich so viel über WMD im Irak geschrieben, wenn wir das gar nicht wussten? So, der nächste Schritt, das übrigens ursprünglich kommt das von dieser Promi-Berichterstattung, die auch völlig schizophren ist. Wenn ihr euch mal so Frauenzeitung oder so anguckt, also diese diese Mode-Magazine, oder so Teenie-Magazine, die irgendwie irgendwelchen Stars hinterher stellen, da ist es seit einer Weile Teil des Zyklus, dass die dann nach einer Weile sagen, lass doch mal den armen Justin Bieber in Ruhe. Ja, aber das sagen genau die, die vorher die Paparazzi bezahlt haben und sie immer noch bezahlen dafür, dass sie diesen Leuten hinterher stalken. Die fangen dann plötzlich an, völlig schizophren zu sagen, na wieso macht die Presse das eigentlich? Und das ist halt bei diesen WMD, es gab so ein Crossover, das gibt es jetzt auch in normalen Medien. Auch die Tagesschau fängt irgendwann an zu sagen, na ja, die Medien haben da auch teilweise so unkritisch drüber berichtet, aber nicht wir. Und ja, das ist ein neuer Trend und der hat jetzt auch den Spiegel erreicht. Der Hermut Schaubasch hat neulich mal gelistet, da ist mir das zum ersten Mal aufgefallen in deutschen Medien, wie unpräzise die Quellenlage da eigentlich ist, was da alles für konkurrierende und widersprüchliche Behauptungen.
Aber das passiert deswegen, weil du eine Story machst, wo du eine Story bringst, musst du halt quasi, musst du Fakten, Fakten, Fakten an den Start bringen, damit das sozusagen wirklich gebracht werden darf. Es ist immer noch verpönt zu sagen, also wir wissen es nicht genau, aber es gibt folgende Stimmen, das ist sozusagen, was eigentlich das Normale ist. Das Normale wäre zu sagen, wir haben da gehört das. So, und das ist aber noch relativ verpönt. Also ich hoffe, dass sich das durchsetzt. Ich hoffe, dass ich es vor allem bei den Öffentlich-Rechtlichen durchsetzen kann, weil die am meisten Platz haben, um so was zu machen. Aber dazu müsste, müsste halt der Journalismus an sich das auch mal sozusagen klar sehen. Du gibst da natürlich ein bisschen Absolutheitsanspruch ab und das fällt glaube ich schwer, aber wäre auf eine Lösung. Ich finde immer, ein schönes Bild dafür sind Filmkritiker. Du kannst ja zu einem beliebigen Medium gehen und da gibt es einen Filmkritiker. Und dann liest du seine Kritik und denkst, was für ein Unsinn, das war doch voll der Superfilm. Und der Punkt bei dem Filmkritiker ist immer, du kannst nicht eine einzelne Kritik nehmen und dann daraus was machen. Du musst ihm in der Weile zuhören. Nach einem halben Jahr weißt du, wenn der über den Film sagt, dass er geil ist, dann finde ich den auch geil. Es ist ein Actionfilm, die findet er nämlich grundsätzlich scheiße. Ich kann aber trotzdem hingehen. Und dieses sozusagen, du musst das Medium, das du wahrnimmst, auch ein bisschen kennen und ein bisschen einschätzen. Da ist man dann wieder beim Zuhörer. Der muss halt auch ein bisschen mitmachen. Und das Medium muss halt sagen, wir wissen auch nicht alles.
Also ich finde, das ist ein Trend, den ich seit einer Weile beobachte. Also früher hieß es, die Tagesschau hat irgendwie gesagt, Barschel ist tot. Dann gab es irgendwann den Trend zu sagen, bei manchen Meldungen, wie der Spiegel in seiner Vorab-Bla am Montag berichtet wird. Also diese, dass man überhaupt sagt, die Meldung kommt nicht von uns, sondern wir beziehen uns hier auf die Berichterstattung in, was weiß ich. Das ist ein Trend, das gibt es seit einer Weile.
Das ist aber Werbung, das ist Magazinwerbung. Also gerade dieses, das ist Werbung für Magazine und oder Fernsehsendung. Das kann man sehr häufig feststellen, weil du kriegst dann, das Ding ist ja, du bist als Nachrichtenredakteur oder als tagesaktuelle Redakteur bist du immer in einer Zeitknappheit.
Wie, du kriegst da ein Kickback für oder so?
Nein, das funktioniert ein bisschen subtiler. Das Ding ist, du kannst ein Thema bringen, wenn du eine Quelle benennen kannst. Es ist sehr schwierig, Themen, also je härter sie werden, desto mehr müssen sie eine Quelle haben. Und das Ding ist, wie das Nachrichten, das ehemalige Nachrichtenmagazin, wie man so schon sagt, das ist halt eine Quelle, die du nennen kannst. Der Punkt ist aber, weil die das in ihr Mord gegen Heft bringen, du aber heute eine Sendung hast, kannst du das A nicht selber nachrecherchieren und du hast keine andere Quelle dafür. Also sagst du in deinem Beitrag, das ehemalige Nachrichtenmagazin hat gesagt, komm mal das. Und was passiert ist, das ehemalige Nachrichtenmagazin hat dafür gesorgt, dass der Name erwähnt wurde und die Leute sich möglicherweise das Heft kaufen. Das funktioniert auch mit Fernsehbeiträgen, also irgendwie das Magazin-Bildschirmgerät hat morgen einen spannenden Beitrag über EPA mit dem Chaos Computer Club.
Ich hab das neulich beim Bayern-Kurier beobachtet, was das Parteimagazin der CSU ist, weil das jemandem nichts sagt. Die haben den Innenminister interviewt von Bayern und der hat irgendwie ein Statement rausgehauen, was auch mal wieder kaum zu überbieten war, wo er meinte, wenn Politiker nichts dagegen tun, dass Gewalt, also gemeint waren die Castor-Gegner, wenn die das nicht abkanzeln, dann seien wir quasi auf dem besten Weg zu einer neuen RAF. Also die Linksterroristen von den Castor-Gegnern. Und es war eine an Demlichkeit kaum zu überbietender Spruch und ich wollte da gerne drauf linken. Aber ich hab's nur beim Spiegel gefunden, der sich auf den Bayern-Kurier bezogen hat und der Bayern-Kurier selber hat es noch nicht. Und da hab ich, also das erklärt es jetzt, dass es einfach Werbung ist, dass die gern ihren Namen in der Presse haben wollen. Aber das finde ich total überhaupt nicht nachvollziehbar, weil ich habe ja den Anspruch, meine Quelle nicht nur zu nennen, sondern darauf zu linken. Und wieso haben die das dann nicht, wenigstens auf ihrer eigenen Webseite? Damit man das tun kann. Weil ich hatte an der Stelle die Option, ich kann jetzt entweder zum Spiegel denken, was ich gerade mal aus fundamental terroristischen Gründen nicht tun will, oder ich kann zur Originalquelle denken, was ich eigentlich tun wollte, nämlich den Bayern-Kurier, aber der hat es noch nicht gehabt. Und das ist eigentlich total der Schuss in den Ofen an der Stelle.
Ja gut, aber das dann sozusagen, da hat die Marketing-Abteilung nicht aufgepasst. Das kann man eher vermuten, dass der Bayern-Kurier sozusagen, was du da machst, ist natürlich auf deine eigene Seite auch eine Verabmeldung stellen, wo dann drin steht, eben mal eine morgige Ausgabe können sie übrigens lesen, komm mal das. Oder ist es halt möglich, dass der gute Minister nicht wichtig genug war, um genau so was an den Start zu bringen. Aber normalerweise hast du genau das. Na ja, jetzt halt, wenn die Aufregung groß genug war. Normalerweise ist es ja, bei Fernsehsendungen sieht man das total gut. Und auch bei Magazinen, die haben dann so einen Vorabartikel. Der ist dann so zwei bis drei Absätze lang, steht drin so, ja, hier irgendwie Hacker des TCC haben gezeigt, dass der neue Personalausweis total sicher ist. Mehr dazu heute Abend um 21.15 Uhr oder morgen in Ausgabe 43.
So, wie kommt das eigentlich, dass wenn, sagen wir mal, der Spiegel oder die Tagesschau in ihrer Online-Ausgabe über, sagen wir den TCC berichten, dass sie da nicht einen Link da rein machen? Also wir haben ja eine Webseite, wo wir Presseerklärungen veröffentlichen als TCC. Und also das kann man seit Jahren beobachten, dass die vermehrt über uns berichten, aber nur in Ausnahmefällen mal einen Link setzen. Und also, ich meine, das ist ja schon eine Sache, wenn sie uns als Quelle nennen, das ist ja an sich schon gut. Aber so diese, was ich völlig selbstverständlich finde, wenn ich irgendjemanden zitiere, dass ich dann auch einen Link setze, wieso ist denn das bei den öffentlich-rechtlichen und überhaupt bei den etablierten Medien noch nicht so?
Na, ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen, da kann ich jetzt tatsächlich nur spekulieren, weil ich habe bei beiden nicht gearbeitet und ich versuche das selber mal zu machen, wenn ich in einen Online-Artikel schreibe. Es gibt natürlich die ganz menschliche Erklärung. Also bei der Tagesschau könnt ihr mir zum Beispiel vorstellen, da gibt es sozusagen ein relativ striktes Management von wegen, die Inhalte müssen online, die sind halt in der 2015 und dann müssen die halt auch auf der Seite sein. So, und was die eigentlich interessante Frage ist, verlinken sie nur den TTC nicht oder verlinken sie generell keine Quellen?
Nee, generell nicht.
Also generell keine Quellen.
Diese Idee, dass man seine Quellen nicht verlinkt, finde ich total abstoßend bei den ganzen Medien.
Also tendenziell ist das, es gab mal eine Zeit lang die Angst, es gibt ja immer diese schönen Brüche hier, wir übernehmen keine Haftung für die Blablabla. Ach so, das kann natürlich sein. Ich hab mal mit einem CMS gearbeitet bei einem Sender. Doch, doch. Aber da hattest du unter jedem CMS, das Konzernmanagement-System, da hattest du sozusagen, unter jedem Link, der extern ging, hattest du diesen Spruch drunter. Überall auf der Seite. Das ist relativ großartig. Die Öffentlich-Rechtlichen haben dann noch mal ein zusätzliches Problem, weil sie immer befürchten müssen, dass sie wegen des Rundfunkstaatsänderungsvertrags angekackt werden, weil da Werbung möglicherweise dahinter ist. Also ich meine, da geht es jetzt nicht um die Tätigkeit, da geht es darum, warum man mit externen Links generell sparsam ist. Und der Punkt ist zum Beispiel beim Nachrichtenmagazin. Du kannst, also es gibt als öffentlich-rechtlicher Sendung, darfst du nirgendswo hin verlinken, wo gezielt Sachen verkauft werden. Also wenn du dich verdächtig machst, zu einem Online-Shop verlinkt zu haben, ist es relativ schwierig. Das ist bei dem Jugendcenter total großartig, wo du sogenannte kurze Infobändchen machst, wo du vorstellst, wie hier neue Glitzerröckchen, total geil, letzte Schrei in Berlin, möchtest du euch alle anziehen, gibt es dort und dort.
Aber dann kannst du nicht sagen, wo es es gibt.
Gibt es dort und dort im Online? Ne, doch, du kannst sagen, wo es es gibt. Man kann die Leute googeln. Es war eine Zeit lang sogar so, nein, du konntest die URL auf die Webseite schreiben.
Aber nicht den Link?
Aber nicht den Link. So, das ist so die Perversität.
Beim Spiegel ist es glaube ich eher so, dass sie doch bei den anderen Zeitungen, dass sie vermeiden wollen, dass die Leute weggehen von der Seite.
Das ist genau, das ist der zweite Punkt. Also der erste Punkt sozusagen. Aufriss möglicher juristischer, befürchtet juristischer Aufriss. Und der andere ist, dass es im Internet und gerade bei klassischen Medien noch diese relativ irrige Vorstellung gibt, von ja, wir müssen die Leute ja bei uns auf der Seite halten.
Das ist ein Portalanspruch.
Ich habe in Redaktionen schon relativ heftige Kämpfe geführt für Leute, die User sind erwachsen genug. Und wenn du machst dich sozusagen eher zum Freund der User, wenn du sagst, pass mal auf, das ist das Thema, das halten wir davon und hier, hier, hier und hier kannst du dich da weiter informieren oder das sind unsere Quellen. Dann hast du eher die Chance, dass der User denkt, okay, da kann ich dann nachher nochmal weiterklicken. Jetzt gucke ich erstmal, was es hier noch gibt. Als wenn du sagst, wir halten dich hier, du kommst nicht raus, you cannot pass. Das ist wirklich so auch eins von diesen ganz alten, also als ob das auf der Zehngebotetafel gestanden hätte. Der User darf nicht umschalten und ein Link ist ja so eine Art Umschalten.
Legen sie die Fernbedienung weg, jetzt kommt zwar Werbung, aber bleiben sie bei uns.
Das wächst sich langsam aus, aber langsam.
Also ich hab eine Weile vermutet, dass das ein Problem mit der Software ist, dass die einfach keine Links können beim Spiegel. Aber dann gab es beim Spiegel irgendwann Leute in der Online-Redaktion, also die haben halt so spezielle Internetbereich in ihrer Pornorama-Sektion und die haben plötzlich Links gehabt. Und da hab ich mir gedacht, na die können das einfach nicht, die anderen Redakteure. Vielleicht braucht man da irgendwie Spezial-Geheimwissen für.
Also bei diesen großen Medien ist es so, dass es dann auch Fraktionen innerhalb der Redaktion gibt, die halt da der einen oder der anderen Lehre anhängen. Und dementsprechend halt sagen, okay, also wir sind autoritativ, wir sind Nachrichtenquelle, wir verlinken nicht irgendwohin. Diese Spiegel-Oldschool-Ideologie, wenn die über irgendwas berichten müssen, was nicht von ihnen kommt, also wo sie nicht die Nachrichtenquelle sind, von denen alle an abschreunden, dann leiden die ganz schrecklich. Was ist denn irgendwas, was irgendwie, denn überlassen sie ja den Praktikanten, dann die Meldung dazu dafür zu schreiben.
Ich möchte aber noch mal kurz auf diese, möglicherweise können die das nicht. Tatsächlich zu sagen, dass das CMS, von dem ich vorhin berichtet habe, mit den externen Links. Das ist ja also heute die meisten der geneigten Hörer, kennen wahrscheinlich Wordpress oder irgendeinen Visivik-Editor im Netz, wo man sozusagen seinen Text mit dem Mauskursor markiert, dann einen Knopf drückt, den Link einfügt und dann war's das. Um einen Link diesem CMS einzufügen, muss man Folgendes machen. Man muss auf die Startseite des CMS gehen, dort in die Links-Sektion, dort einen neuen Link anlegen. Dazu musstest du einpflegen URL, Titel des Links, Quelle des Links, wann es aufgenommen wurde, Verschlagwortung des Links, damit es auch wiedergefunden werden kann. Dann musstest du es abspeichern, dann musstest du den abgespeicherten Link freigeben, damit er auch online gesehen ist. Dann musstest du in dem Artikel, den du gerade schreibst, die Link einfügen Box aufrufen, wo du in der Suchmacht herkommst, die in dem Linkteil des Systems des CMS nach diesem Link suchst. Dort musstest du den Link suchen, dann musstest du den einfügen, dann hattest du in der Editormaske am Rand einen Link, also sagen wir so eine kleine Box, wo alle eingefügten Links sind. Und dann musstest du den noch im Dokument platzieren, musstest aber darauf achten, dass es in der richtigen Formatierung passiert, sonst hast du dir möglicherweise den Editor so zerschossen, dass das ganze Ding abgestürzt ist. Das ist wahrscheinlich heute anders, es ist schon eine Weile her, als wir mit diesem Thema erst gearbeitet haben, aber in der Tat hat man sich manchmal überlegt, wenn man so halbe Stunde vor Freierabend, der Artikel muss noch fertig werden.
Och nö, doch keine Linksammlung.
Nee, ich glaube heute nicht. Oh mein. Da sind wir wieder beim Wasser kochen.
Das erklärt aber echt einiges.
Du hattest doch neulich irgendwie so eine Statistik, wie viele Leute bei uns eigentlich die Linksammlung durcharbeiten. Also wir kriegen, wir sind irgendwie 10% oder so.
Ja, so etwa 10%, ja.
Aber wir kriegen gelegentlich Feedback. Also alles Feedback, was wir zu den Links kriegen, ist eigentlich positiv, obwohl nicht viele drauf klicken.
Das ist aber genau, was ich vorhin meinte. Du musst mal versuchen, mach doch mal eine Sendung, wo du viel über Sachen redest und machst keine Links. Der Shitstorm wäre wahrscheinlich relativ...
Das haben wir in der ersten Sendung gehabt. Da sind wir nicht dazu gekommen und haben das dann auch nachträglich nicht gemacht. Und also es war jetzt kein Shitstorm, aber es war schon...
Naja, aber mittlerweile wird es wahrscheinlich gut funktionieren. Es wären wahrscheinlich mehr Aufreger, als Leute, die Links klicken.
Na, oder auf jeden Fall.
Ja, klappt.
Also ich halt... Ich mach dir ja auch für mich selbst so ein bisschen die Links an, oder?
Notizen, ja. Das wird auch so ein bisschen so...
Wenn man später mal was widersucht.
Wo haben wir denn drüber geredet und wo haben wir denn dieses Bit eigentlich her?
Apropos Konzentrationsschwäche, ne?
Wieso?
Naja, also unser Gehirn ist die Linksarbeitung zur Sendung.
Das ist dann aber tatsächlich eine Merk-Schwäche, ne? Ist keine Konzentrationsschwäche. Das ist ja nicht so, dass wir nicht beim Thema bleiben können, sondern dass die Informationsmenge so groß ist, dass du externe Hilfe und Stütze brauchst. Das ist aber normal. Also das hat früher ein Notizbuch genommen.
Das ist so ein Spiegelding, kann man sich auch nicht merken mit den Zahlenkolonnen. Das ist ja wie so eine Safe-Kombination.
Ich glaube aber auch, dass das Verhalten ihr, dass das das Medienverhalten gerade verändert, weil wenn man ganz weit zurückgeht, früher hattest du einen Stadtausrufer. Der Stadtausrufer war in Süditalien, ist zurückgekommen, hat erzählt, alter krass, Pest, richtig heftig. Und dann war das halt deine Quelle. Konntest du weiter erzählen? Der Typ war da, irgendwie hat er den Pest in Italien gesehen, krasses Teil. Und je mehr Internet wir haben, desto mehr Anspruch auf Vollständigkeit der Quellen haben wir auch. Und das ist natürlich, die Linksammlung wird immer länger und kein Mensch kann die lesen.
Also wie gesagt, einige arbeiten die durch. Wir haben sogar mal Feedback gekriegt, machen die so schnell die nächste Sendung. Bin mit dem Link aber noch nicht durch. Was ich ja sehr schwit finde. Also solches Feedback kriegen wir sehr gern.
Ja, also überhaupt das Feedback meistens relativ gut so. Aber die Frage eben nach genau, wie wird denn, wenn dann diese Techniken ausgenutzt, dass die Leute sich das nicht mehr merken können. Das war auch sehr interessant. Und zwar auch bei einer Nachrichtenagentur, einem Redakteur da gesprochen, gefragt so naja, ihr habt ja manchmal da so Meldungen drin, die klingen nach so PR-Bullshit. Also als ob ihr da irgendeine PR-Meldung reinbekommen habt. Dann meinte er naja, am Wochenende haben wir hier so doppeldaumendicke Stapel im Faxgerät. Von irgendwelchen vorgefertigten PR-Bullshit-Meldungen, die gerne wollen, dass wir daraus Meldungen machen. So und die sind halt, das ist halt so, dass bei so einer Agentur ist natürlich immer ein massiver Multiplikator. Und das heißt, wenn du da reinkommst, dann bist du automatisch halt, hast du eine gute Chance, zumindest in diesen ganzen Zeitungen, die sowieso nur noch DPA-Print von gestern sind oder was auch immer ihre Agentur gerade ist, halt drin zu sein. So und die Aufgabe, diesen Kram auszusortieren, ist halt echt hart. Weil da sind durchaus auch Meldungen dabei, Sachen, bei die tatsächlich eine Meldung werden können. Aber da gibt es halt auch jede Menge Leute, die offensichtlich immer wieder versuchen, da reinzukommen. Und wenn du dir anguckst, die Quote von PR-Beratern oder Leuten, die in die PR für Unternehmen oder für Agenturen gehen und tatsächlichen Journalisten. Wir sind mittlerweile so weit, dass es mehr Leute gibt, die PR machen als Journalisten. Also tatsächlich Leute, die irgendwie bei Agenturen oder bei Sendern und dergleichen Dingen mehr arbeiten. Das heißt also der Informationsdruck auf die Medien, der durch diesen ganzen Bullshit, der da kommt, passiert, wird halt auch immer größer. Also es ist halt teilweise offen, weil es irgendwie so gerade in der Spielebranche oder so ist vermutlich noch relativ straight forward und...
Na im Gegenteil, da gibt es einen gewaltigen Druck. Wenn du da einmal ein Review machst, der nicht irgendwie genehm ist, dann kannst du richtig auf die Fresse kriegen. Also hier noch nicht so, aber in Amerika.
Na das erlebe ich tatsächlich anders. Also in der Tat, ich würde von den Zahlen her auch sagen, dass es viel mehr Leute, die PR arbeiten als Spielejournalisten. Also festengestellte Spielejournalisten. Was dann wieder ein interessanter Punkt ist, PR wird einfach besser bezahlt, also langfristig. Das ist halt die Frage, wer bezahlt unsere Medien. Aber es ist in der Tat, kommt es ab und zu mal vor, dass man ein Spiel verreißt. Und dann kriegst du lustigerweise, du kriegst nie auf ein positives Review, also wenn du sagst, geiles Spiel, voll drauf hängen geblieben, schickst du einen Belegexemplar an die Agentur und dann ist es halt gut. Wenn du ein schlechtes Review machst, dann kommt natürlich die Frage, Entschuldigung, was ist es, warum? Und der Punkt ist dann, dass es, glaube ich, tatsächlich einfach, also ich habe es bis jetzt nur so erlebt, muss ich an dieser Stelle sagen. Ich habe dann erklärt, ich finde das Spiel aus folgenden Gründen scheiße. KI ist schlecht, Grafikfehler und...
Es stürzt ab und die Safe Games sind korrumpiert. Ansonsten ein geiles Spiel, aber...
Und dann ist es aber auch gut. Dann ist es halt so und es hat auch noch keinerlei, wie heißt das jetzt, also Strafmaßnahmen bekommen, weil es dann keine Spiele mehr von der Firma bekommen hätte oder so.
Sanktionen.
Ich glaube, dass die Agenturen, die für so Spielefirmen arbeiten, mittlerweile auch ganz genau wissen, wann ein Spiel sozusagen gut ist oder nicht. Man kann das zum Beispiel daran feststellen, wenn es schwierig ist, an ein Spiel zu kommen, das relativ viel vor Abpresse bekommen hat, dann ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass es scheiße ist, relativ hoch. Und den Leuten ist also klar, sie können nichts mehr dagegen machen. Deswegen gehen die Muster dann ein bisschen später raus.
Verstehe. Das heißt, sie versuchen dann die die Zeitspanne für die Verrisse zu verringern. Aber interessant ist ja, dass die Mechanismen in der Politik funktionieren ja doch eher expliziter. Da ist es ja so, dass offensichtlich die Journalisten oder deren Chefredakteure Angst davor haben, dass sie eben zum Beispiel keine Interviews mehr kriegen oder dass sie nicht mehr mit auf die Ministerflüge dürfen und dergleichen Dinge mehr, wenn sie sich nicht genehm verhalten. Also wenn sie halt da Dinge publizieren oder Fragen stellen, die unerwünscht sind. Und diese Manipulation, das Entziehen des Zugriffs zur Macht, ist ja auch genau das, was halt zum Beispiel halt beim Spiegel oder bei anderen Nachrichtenmagazinen halt sehr effizient wirkt, die ja darauf angewiesen sind, dass sie in diesem Newsflow drin sind, dass sie halt denen die Information zugesteckt bekommen, dass sie die SMSen aus der Kabinettssitzung bekommen und dergleichen Dinge mehr, um halt eben wieder vorne dabei zu sein. Und diese Drohung mit dem Liebesentzug wirkt da doch sehr effizient. Also wenn man so mit politischen Journalisten in Berlin redet, die natürlich namentlich niemals genannt werden wollen würden, sind diese Maßnahmen gerade jetzt so in den, also eigentlich seit Gerhard Schröder, muss man sagen, der hat damit angefangen, Systematisch zu betreiben, sind die schon sehr explizit geworden. Also so, dass sie halt einfach dann noch gesagt bekommen, so ne, du jetzt gerade mal nicht, oder tut mir leid, ne, sie heute nicht. Und damit halt einfach auch so das Risiko, also das Berufsrisiko namentlich Kritik zu üben an Vorgängen, an Regierung, an Entscheidungen oder auch an Panikmache, eben entsprechend hoch geworden ist. Und dann man sich das dann einfach nicht mehr leisten kann. Und selbst wenn es einem selber egal wäre, weil man kann ja auch über keine Ahnung, man muss ja nicht über Innenpolitik schreiben, man kann ja auch über Computerspiele schreiben, dann ist es aber trotzdem so fürs Medium nicht. Also es wird dann häufiger mal die gesamte Zeitung abgewatscht und die bekommt dann halt eben keinen Zugang mehr oder dergleichen Dinge mehr. Und diese Manipulation, die da stattfindet, hat glaube ich auch einen großen Einfluss darauf, wie staatsglaubig mittlerweile z.B. Interviews geführt werden. Also früher kann ich mich erinnern, wenn man so mal alte Spiegel aus den 70ern anguckt, da haben die noch so richtige Kracher-Interviews drin, also richtig so mit irgendwie mal Nachbohren und mal irgendwie eben nicht irgendwie so diese üblichen Wischiwaschi-Geschichten und so Wohlfühlgeschichten, sondern halt mal so richtig draufgeklopft. Und heutzutage ist das Risiko dann offensichtlich zu groß. Was dann auch sicherlich damit zu tun hat, dass häufig genug solche Interviews dann eben autorisiert werden müssen und es halt also das gesprochene Wort nicht mehr zählt.
Das ist ein interessanter Effekt, den ich tatsächlich nur beobachte. Also ich schätze mich deine glücklichen Lage, in einem kleinen Medium zu arbeiten, wo du halt öfter auch mal sagen kannst, nee, ich wollte ihn eigentlich nicht vorab die Frageliste schicken, weil ich möchte gerne ein Lebendiges Interview. Und nee, ich will ihn nicht. Die geschnittene sozusagen, also sie können das gerne vorher hören, aber nicht zensieren.
Die Vorlage, das ist auch so ein Ding, das habe ich meinem amerikanischen Freund erzählt und der wollte mir nicht glauben, dass es das hier gibt.
Dass man das vorlegen muss?
Ja, dass du das dem Interviewtyp nochmal vorlegst, damit er die Sachen, die ihm nicht genehm sind, an seinen eigenen Aussagen rausschneiden kann. Das finde ich auch eher bedenklich.
Das ist aber mittlerweile vollständig üblich. Also wenn ich für eine CCC-Presse Arbeit mache, ist es so, dass es mittlerweile von ziemlich vielen Journalisten angeboten wird. Ich biete das halt an, dass ich sage, ich gucke gerne noch mal drüber, damit es sachlich korrekt ist. Weil wir häufiger technisch zusammenhängend lernen, dass ich sage, ich gucke da gerne drüber, was sachlich korrekt ist. Aber ansonsten, da mache ich mir nicht an, noch mal rein zu korrigieren. Und das finden viele Journalisten sehr ungewöhnlich. Sie sind gewohnt, dass sie dann von irgendwelchen PR-Knechten zu recht geschliffene Formulierungen zurückkommen, die überhaupt nicht mehr nach einem möglichen Interview klingen, sondern nur noch nach sonst irgendwas. Und das andere Ding, was auch sehr häufig passiert ist, dass mittlerweile Interviews nur noch per E-Mail gemacht werden. Also das ist halt einfach die Kontrolle, die dadurch, dass du nicht mehr live sprichst, sondern nur einen Augenblick Zeit hast, drüber nachzudenken und deine Antwort zu formulieren und im Gesamtkontext dessen der Fragen.
Der Zugzwang fällt weg.
Ja, der Zugzwang fällt weg und du siehst halt auch alle Fragen in der Auflistung und so. Das denke ich mir halt auch noch einen großen Einfluss darauf. Also, dass eben da mittlerweile politische Brisanz in den Medien halt immer weniger stattfindet. Aber ein wichtiger Punkt, den wir auf jeden Fall noch erwähnen sollten, ist, dass diese, das Ganze ist ja Bestandteil eines großen Kontexts und der Kontext ist, dass man kann es eigentlich mittlerweile so auf die Machtübernahme von New Labour zurückführen in Europa, ist, dass dieses Spin-Doctoring, also die Art und Weise wie ein Projekt, ein politisches Projekt in den Medien verkauft wird und die Art und Weise wie dafür gesorgt wird, dass es den richtigen Namen hat, dass es ja ein stundes Image bekommt, dass es das richtige Logo hat und dergleichen Dinge mehr, dass das hat halt angefangen damit, dass also als die Blair-Click da an die Macht kam und den ja ihre sogenannten Reformprojekte, die halt im Wesentlichen nichts weiter waren als das Geld halt irgendwie zu denen, die schon genug Geld hatten schaufeln, das halt irgendwie verkauft werden musste. Mittlerweile sind wir da in...
Ist ja bei uns auch so Reform-Ansprache.
Die haben es eins zu eins übernommen. Die SPD hat ja tonnenweise Berater und Politlinge dahingeschickt und haben sich das angucken. Guckt euch das ab. Guckt euch das ab bei New Labour. Und die Bertelsmänner mit ihrer Initiative für neue soziale Marktwirtschaft, die sind ja da ganz vorne mit dabei. Da geht es ja eben genau darum, eben nicht mehr zu, ja, also Politik zu machen, sondern nur noch sie zu verkaufen. Ja, also eines dieser Beispiele für diese Korrekturen, die da New Labour an der öffentlichen Wahrnehmung vorgenommen hat, war ja der Versuch, ihre sozialen Reformen, die sie da durchgeführt haben, als Verbesserungen zu verkaufen. Am Ende war es ja so, dass es halt dazu führte, dass irgendwie alle, die in London noch eine Wohnung haben wollten, mindestens zwei, manche sogar drei Jobs haben mussten, und es halt irgendwie kaum noch möglich war, irgendwie ein anständiges Leben zu führen für Leute, die jetzt nicht gerade einen Job in der Bank oder an der Werbungantur hatten. Was auch so ein Punkt war, genau dieses ganze Spin-Doctoring, also dieses Labeln von irgendwie der Abschaffung der Arbeitslosenversicherung als, was hier dann auch passiert ist, hieß es dann nicht mehr Arbeitsamt, sondern hieß es dann nur noch Agentur für Beschäftigung. Das sind dann halt so genau diese Umbenennungen, die halt da auch da...
Bei mir heißen die immer noch Arbeitsamt.
Passiert sich... Ja klar, wir erinnern uns da halt noch dran, dass es irgendwie früher mal Arbeitsamt hieß und dass es auch genau das war, worum es da eigentlich ging, nämlich ein Amt, wo man irgendwie hingehen ging, wenn man keine Arbeit hatte und nicht irgendwas, wo sie einen, ja, belästigen.
Beschäftigungstherapie.
Ja, und diese Art und Weise der Umdeutung durch Begriffe ist ja eine Kunst, die immer mehr zugenommen hat und die immer mehr auch in den öffentlichen Raum gegangen ist, bis wir auch selber angefangen haben, sie zu benutzen. Also zum Beispiel die Geschichte mit den wahlcomputern. So, es war halt so, dass der Hersteller nennt die Dinge halt Wahlmaschinen. Und um zu suggerieren, dass es sich dabei um, naja, so Maschinen handelt, die nichts anderes können, also die halt nur rein mechanisch diese Funktion ausführen und da kann man gar nichts machen. Wir nennen sie halt wahlcomputer, das ist, was sie sind. Also Computer, die man umprogrammieren kann und da im Zweifel auch Schacht drauf spielen kann, statt damit zu wählen. Aber wir benutzen diese Mechanismen natürlich auch, um halt politische Schlachten zu gewinnen oder irgendwie die Welt zu verbessern. Aber am Ende ist es so, dass eben alle das tun. Und halt der Effekt, der da entsteht, ist halt so ein Spin-Doctoring to Death. Das heißt selbst, wenn jemand daherkommt, der jetzt ein völlig integerer, vertrauenswürdiger Politiker wäre. Also wir nehmen mal, nehmen wir mal rein hypothetisch an, dass gäbe eine gesellschaftliche Situation, die dazu führen würde, dass jemand, der vollständig integere und sonst wie auch untatlich ist, an die Regierung kommt, selbst dem würde niemand mehr glauben. Es gibt ja keine inhärente Glaubwürdigkeit dieses Berufsstandes mehr. Selbst wenn die Leute aussehen wie der Präsident aus dem Fernsehen und die beste Nachrichtenmoderator-Stimme haben, glauben tut ihnen trotzdem niemand mehr so recht.
Aber das ist doch schon länger so, oder? Ich meine, deswegen sind wir jetzt zu diesem Alternativlos übergegangen. Früher sind einfach Sachen umgedeutet worden, aber heute wird einfach dir direkt ins Gesicht gelogen und gesagt, es gibt überhaupt keine Alternative. Also da werden quasi die Fakten umgeändert, nicht mehr die Interpretation, sondern also so weit sind wir ja schon im politischen Diskurs, dass einfach Fakten geleugnet werden. Und das habe ich ja lange nicht verstanden, um mal so ein bisschen den Übergang zu schaffen, das habe ich ja lange nicht verstanden, wie das überhaupt eine sinnvolle Strategie sein kann. Wenn ich dir direkt ins Gesicht lüge, dann fällt dir das auch mal eine Stunde später auf, also soll man jetzt irgendwie mit Verzögerung durch Nachrichten und keine Ahnung. Und dann weißt du doch, dass ich gelogen habe und dann ist auch meine Argumentation dahin. Aber das stellt sich raus, ein Freund von mir schreibt gerade ein Buch über Computerspiele AI, also künstliche Intelligenz in Trollen auf dem Bildschirm. Und die Parallelen zwischen einer Computerspiele AI und einem tatsächlichen Gehirn sind schockierend groß. Also ich habe neulich ein Buch gelesen, das haben wir im letzten Alternativlos schon kurz angesprochen, nämlich Influence the Art of Persuasion von Robert Chialdini. Das ist ein Psychologieprofessor in den USA. Und da geht es um Manipulationen und natürlich hauptsächlich Verkaufen. Denn das ist ja traditionell, wofür Manipulationen und ihre Leute bezahlt werden. Aber der beschreibt eben so ein paar Mechanismen, wie man das Gehirn bescheißen kann. Und das ist scheiße spannend. Und weil das so spannend ist, möchte ich es ein bisschen ausführen. Also, wenn man einen Computerspiele AI programmiert, so ein Troll.
AI ist Artificial Intelligence.
Genau, also wenn man die Software programmiert, die so den Gegner in einem Computerspiel steuert, dann hat man Echtzeitanforderungen. Also man möchte gerne, dass der so schnell reagiert, wie man ihn anspricht. Und das gelingt natürlich immer nur teilweise. Deswegen, also man formuliert irgendwelche Anforderungen. Man möchte gerne, dass der in sinnvoller Zeit antwortet. Und da gibt es eben den einfachen Fall, dass der, dass offensichtlich ist, was er tun soll. Zum Beispiel, weil ich gerade mit meinem Schwert nach ihm schlage, dann muss er halt versuchen auszuweichen. Und den kann man eben hardcoden. Das heißt, so ähnlich macht das das Gehirn auch. Das Gehirn guckt, für die Entscheidung, die ich gerade treffen will, gibt es da eine offensichtliche Antwort. Ist das ein einfaches Problem, dann löse ich das sofort. Und dann ist es rational. Aber wenn ich zu lange brauche, um diese Entscheidung zu treffen, dann ist es offensichtlich kein einfaches Problem. Und dann gibt es Fallbacks, auf die das Gehirn zurückweicht. Und das ist ähnlich, wie man es bei einer AI im Spiel programmieren würde. Und die Fallbacks kann man eben ausnutzen an der Stelle. Und warum ich das jetzt erwähne, ist, dass dieses Zeitintervall genau das ist, was man mit dem dreisten Lügen ausnutzt. Also wenn mir ein Politiker dreist ins Gesicht, lügt, zum Beispiel, es muss ja kein Politiker sein, es kann auch die Tabakindustrie sein, die sagt, nein, das ist gar nicht klar, oder Global Warming, die Klimaerwärmung, das ist gar nicht klar, da geht es nicht darum, mich zu überzeugen. Das habe ich immer gedacht, dass sie einfach inkompetent sind und mich eigentlich überzeugen wollen. Aber das ist gar nicht der Hintergrund, sondern der Hintergrund ist, mich lang genug aufzuhalten in meinen Prozessen, in meinen Denkprozessen, dass ich von dem rationalen entscheiden Zurückfalle auf die Heuristiken, auf die Verfahren.
Basisfunktionen.
Genau, Basisfunktionen, Verfahren, die nicht klar definiert sind, sondern die so Faustregeln folgen. Ja, und darum geht es, wenn dir jemand so richtig ins Gesicht liegt, dann möchte der dir dich gar nicht überzeugen, sondern der möchte gern, dass du feststellst, das ist vielleicht doch kein so einfaches Problem, na dann vertraue ich mal der Autorität. Das ist zum Beispiel eine der Strategien. Das heißt, das ist so eine Zwei-Stufen-Strategie üblicherweise, A, man sät so ein bisschen Unsicherheit. Unsicherheit ist so ein Katalysator an der Stelle. Man schafft das, die Leute sich unsichern oder alleine fühlen. Das ist ein anderer Katalysator. Und dann dafür sorgt, dass es eine Autoritätsfigur gibt oder dass es einen Herde gibt, den man folgen kann. Das sind so die Haupt-Heuristiken an der Stelle. Dann kann man die Leute dazu bringen, dass sie Sachen tun, die sie eigentlich nicht tun wollten.
Ja, es sind halt ein Zurückfahren darauf, einfach auf evolutionär entstandene Muster, die halt einfach dem Überleben gedient haben. Und die in normalen Umgebungen auch ganz gut funktionieren. Um das Überleben sicherzustellen. Aber wenn man sie ausnutzt, können sie natürlich echt tricky werden. Das intuitive Handeln in solchen Fällen muss dann nicht zwangsläufig das Richtige sein. Weil dein Gegner nicht mehr die Natur ist, oder der Sebelzahn-Tiger oder das Mammut, sondern jemand anderes, der genau weiß, wie die Mechanismen in deinem Kopf funktionieren und sie eben ausnutzt. Und ja, gerade bei, also bei der, weißt du, was du gerade sagst, das Herdentrieb, ein Großteil der Werbung für Zigaretten war ja eine Zeit lang so, come on, everybody's doing it. Also jeder Vorbildwirkung, Schauspieler, überall, also Rauchen war halt das, was alle getan haben, also wird das schon gut sein.
Der Fallback, wenn du nicht sicher bist, ob du jetzt aufhören musst oder nicht, ist, dass du weitermachst. Das ist ja wie mit Autofahren. Du weißt ja auch, Autofahren ist schlecht für dich. Das weiß jeder, ne? Die Statistiken sind bekannt, wie viele Leute im Verkehr jeweils sterben. Ja, wir wissen, es kostet es eine unglaubliche Umweltverschmutzung, mit dem Auto rumzufahren. Wir wissen, die Straßen zu bezahlen, kostet ein Schweinegeld. Ja, wir wissen, es hat eigentlich fast nur Nachteile und wir sollten eigentlich öffentlichen Nahverkehr nutzen. Aber solange die PR-Agenturen es schaffen, Zweifel zu säen, ob das jetzt wirklich schlimm ist oder ob es da noch einen Twist gibt, vielleicht ist es ja noch nicht zu Ende entschieden. Es gibt ja noch Gegenstimmen. Das ist gerade die Position bei den Klimaveränderungsleugnern. Ja, da gibt es aber noch Gegenpositionen. Die gibt es gar nicht, aber das ist ja nicht der Punkt, weil es ja niemand nachprüft. Das reicht, wenn die Unsicherheit groß genug ist und dann kannst du weitermachen, wie du bisher machst.
Genau dieser eine Mechanismus ist halt, dass der Hirn hat eine Neigung zu geschlossenen Systemen, zu konsistenten Stories. Man bevorzugt Geschichten, die in sich schlüssig sind, die keine Zweifel aufweisen, die nicht irgendwie problematisch sind. Wo halt nicht irgendwie so... Genau das ist auch interessanterweise dieser Punkt. Diese Darstellung in den Medien, dieser neutrale Blick, der in den USA noch sehr viel extremer als hier dadurch pauschal hergestellt wird, dass man immer noch die Gegenmeinung mit dazu publiziert. Also dass man halt einfach immer sagt so, aber es gibt ja noch Zweifel, die oder...
Es gibt noch diesen Crackpot aus Texas, der sagt, der Ölregen ist total ungefährlich, der da gerade von BP verursacht wird. Ja, so ist das tatsächlich in den USA in den Nachrichtengeschichten. Da wird dann zwar berichtet, es regnet hier Öl, weil das Dispersionsmittel dafür gesorgt hat, dass das Wasser aus dem Golf von Mexiko mit dem Öl drin verdunstet und als Regen runterkommt. Aber es gibt auch diesen Crackpot von der Ölindustrie und der sagt, ist alles nicht so schlimm. Der Hintergedanke ist der neutrale Gesichtspunkt, dass man den warnen will, aber das hat den gegenteiligen Effekt.
Weil es eben genau dafür sorgt, dass es eine Verwirrung gibt. Und dann folgt man der nächsten Heuristik und die ist, glaube ich, den Autoritäten. Das ist das, was dir anerzogen ist. Wenn sich ein Professor hinstellt und sagt, die Wissenschaft der Stamm der Dinge ist dieses und jenes, und wie sie an diesem schönen Flohchart sehen können, war das noch nie anders. Und alle anderen, die irgendwas anderes behaupten, sind doch totale Bullshit-Sayer.
Professor ist ja noch zu toppen.
Aber eine kurze Zwischenfrage, das lässt ja für die Medienrücktus zu. Die darf es eigentlich gar nicht geben, weil entweder sie sagen das eine Ding, was sozusagen eine konsistente Story ist, das ist dann aber die falsche. Oder sie stellen dich vor die Wahl und sagen, pass auf, es gibt folgende Standpunkte, bitte entscheide selber. Dann ist es auch die falsche, weil du dann mit dem falschen weiter machst. Also Medien abschaffen oder wie?
Medien haben es nicht einfach.
Nee, geht ja nur erstmal darum, Mechanismen zu sagen. Ich glaube nicht, dass es möglich ist, es besser zu machen. Also daran glaube ich nicht mehr wirklich so. Das ist also ohne Weiteres, man sagen könnte, wenn man das und das besser machen würde, dann wäre es besser. Also das Einzige, was funktionieren würde, wäre, dass man da mehr Geld drauf gibt, damit die Leute mehr Zeit haben, um tatsächlich zum Beispiel nicht dem Crackpot aus Texas nur wegen einem Telefonanruf diesen Blickwinkel zu offerieren. Oder weil eben dann von seiner PA-Agentur eben das Fax reinkam und sagte, übrigens, wenn sie zu diesem Thema was machen, haben wir hier diesen kontrieren Blickpunkt dazu.
Das funktioniert auch aus einer anderen Richtung. Die Perspektive des Dinges, die Blogosphäre oder diese komische Gemeinde im Internet, nimmt ja auch für sich selber Anspruch, wir sind die, die nicht so eine große Reichweite haben, aber wir bringen die Perspektiven auf, die nicht mehr gesehen werden. Das heißt, diese Sendung, die ich habe, die sich mit Internet und so beschäftigt, ist ja genau das der Punkt, ein Thema zu nehmen, was eh gerade am Start ist und dann noch mal ein oder zwei Meinungen zu bringen, die sozusagen genau da kommuniziert werden. Aber wo zieht man denn dann die Grenze oder kann man überhaupt die Grenze ziehen? Und ich dachte, es ist eher sozusagen ein gutes Ding, die Leute vor die Wahl zu stellen, eine Meinung zu haben.
Nein, es geht hier nicht darum, Grenzen zu ziehen. Also ich will, es ist auch keine Kritik, sondern die Hoffnung mit der Sendung hier ist, dass wir so ein bisschen die Mechanismen beleuchten und unseren Hörern dann dabei helfen, das zu merken, wenn sie verarscht werden. Also das arbeitet ja auch für mich gelegentlich, dass ich dann irgendwie als der Crackpot genannt werde und mein Blog funktioniert unter anderem natürlich, weil ich dann ein konsistentes Weltbild habe. Also natürlich, die Mechanismen sind ja nicht nur gegen uns, sondern ich benutze die ja auch selber, um meine Leser zu fangen, ob ich das jetzt absichtlich mache oder nicht, mal dahingestellt. Aber natürlich, das ist nicht per se was schlechtes, sondern das sind alles Dual-Use-Sachen. Aber wenn man die Mechanismen versteht, hat man immerhin eine Chance, dass man sich da wehren kann.
Genau, ganz kurz noch. Das führt mich schon wieder auf die Stelle, wo ich sage, der Zuhörer muss selber also aktiv in dem Sinne werden, dass er sich klar machen muss. Es gibt niemanden, der dir sagen kann, wo du langgehen musst. Und ich glaube, das ist im Umgang mit Medien, also die sogenannte Kompetenz, ein großes Problem, dass die Leute sagen, eigentlich ist es doch immer noch offen, es gibt irgendwo das Grammophon, wo ich mich als Hund davorsetzen kann und reingucke und dann sozusagen nicht mehr selber nachdenken muss. Und das geht nicht.
Daran sind aber die Medien schuld. Denn die Medien haben ein sehr kohärentes Weltbild. Wenn du zum Kiosk gehst und du guckst dir die 20-Tages-Zeitung an, dann siehst du bei 19 von den 20 irgendwie die Schlagzeile Terror-Alarm. Und dadurch kommt dieses Konzept überhaupt zustande, dass es einen Konsens gibt, was gerade wichtig ist. Wenn jede Zeitung was anderes schreiben würde, dann hätte ich als Leser nicht das Gefühl, ich muss mir eigentlich nur den Spiegel holen und da steht schon alles drin. Sondern das Gefühl kommt doch erst dadurch, dass wenn ich mir mal was anderes hole, dann steht eigentlich dieselbe Scheiße drin. Ja, da sind überall dieselben Stories. Also besonders krass fällt einem das auf. Also was heißt, mir ist das besonders krass aufgefallen, weil ich vor ein paar Jahren mal so eine Nachrichtensuchmaschine programmiert hab. Und da habe ich überhaupt erst wahrgenommen, wie kohärent das Medienbild ist. Also vor allem, wie viele einfach direkt DPA-Meldungen drucken. Also Tausende von Zeitungen haben einfach Werbeathemen direkt kopiert, die DPA-Meldung und haben das dann, das war dann direkt ein Auslandsbericht.
Da ist auch niemand mehr. Da ist auch keiner mehr, der was anderes tun könnte.
Aber dadurch entsteht auch überhaupt erst diese Idee, dass die Medien die Wahrheit haben. Wenn die sich alle widersprechen würden, dann käme doch keiner auf die Idee zu sagen, das wird schon die Wahrheit sein. Insofern finde ich das schon, dass man es den Medien angreifen kann an der Stelle.
Na gut, oder ihre Unterfinanzierung kann man natürlich auch sagen.
Ja genau, aber du musst, aber das ist natürlich ein Kritikpunkt, aber ich habe schon das Gefühl, dass es dieses träge Massepublikum schon irgendwo auch gibt. Die Leute, die vielleicht jetzt auch gerade diesen Podcast hören und sich danach super informiert fühlen, aber dann übermorgen wieder eine komische Fernsehsendung gucken und das halt nicht hinterfragen. Weil sie haben ja die Sendung gehört hier und jetzt sind sie ja informiert und das ist halt der Punkt zu sagen, ich glaube, das gibt so eine geistige Faulheit.
Da muss ich mal einen Bonn-Mod kurz erzählen.
Ja bitte.
Also es gibt diese Geschichte, ich glaube, es wird irgendein deutscher Kaiser, aber das ist nochmal Friedrich Wilhelm, der, keine Ahnung, hat irgendein Problem, ruft seinen Berater zu sich, der Berater berät ihn und es dauert irgendwie Stunden und am Ende ist er ganz konsterniert und sagt dem Berater, hör mal, Berater, ich hab dir jetzt drei Stunden zugehört, ich bin jetzt auch nicht schlauer als vorher. Und dann sagt der Berater, das mag sein, aber besser informiert. Und so ist das bei uns natürlich auch, na klar. Also wir haben nicht den Anspruch, dass die Leute danach schlau sind. Im Übrigen möchte ich dir aufs härteste widersprechen, dass uns hier irgendwelche Idioten zuhören. Unsere Zielgruppe sind die besonders gut gebildeten, einkommensstarken.
Also der Vorteil von so Podcasts ist ja, dass man sozusagen immer Konkurrenz zu allem anderen ist. Also du musst nicht an eine Wille gucken, du kannst stattdessen an unseren Podcasts.
Du kannst an eine Wille gucken und währenddessen den Podcasts.
Ja, also ich meine, eine Wille und eine Throne wird wahrscheinlich sogar noch verpissed werden. Böser Mann. Na gut, aber zurück zu den Mechanismen. Diese Geschichte mit dem Charus und dem guten Aussehen haben wir bei Reagan gesehen. Also Reagan ist ja genau deswegen gewählt worden, weil er halt aussah wie so ein Typ, der es halt hinkriegt. Und der hat ja immer noch, wenn du mit Amis redest, gerade etwas konservatives genanntes.
Der ist immer noch ein Held, so eine Lichtfigur.
Der ist ja der Held, der die Sowjetin nur niedergerungen hat. Er war halt da nur die Garjonsfigur. Auf die Idee, die Sowjetin uns zu Tode zu rüsten, sind da andere Leute gekommen, die es dann durchgezogen haben. Aber sie brauchten halt offensichtlich da diese leicht durchgeknallte Cowboyfigur da an der Spitze. Und Schroder, die Nummer mit Schroder und seiner Haarfarbe. Also nichts hat irgendwie ihn offensichtlich so aufgeregt, wie die Verleumdung, oder wie es, glaube ich, der Urteil war, dass es eine Verleumdung war, dass er sich die Haare färbt. Weil, ich weiß nicht, wahrscheinlich würde er grommeliert genauso cool aussehen, aber es ist halt irgendwie so...
Clinton sah ja sogar cooler aus, grommeliert.
Stimmt, ja. Naja.
Aber ist ja auch egal, also wenn man heute Barriere Novosi klickt, da haben sie eine Schlagzeile mit mit Schroder, mit einem Bild, und da sind seine Haare eher noch dunkler als früher insofern.
Das ist bestimmt nur das Licht.
Bestimmt das Licht.
Ja, oder?
Also bei Reagan habe ich neulich eine witzige Analyse gelesen. Da hieß es nämlich, dass die ein TV-Duell hatten zwischen den Präsidenten. Und dass die vorher einfach das tatsächlich als TV-Duell betrachtet haben und da also sich rhetorisch vorbereitet haben. Und Reagan ist da einfach hingegangen und hat in die Kamera gegrinst. Und sah dadurch aus, als habe er die Lage im Griff. Inhaltlich hat er nichts beizutragen gehabt, aber er sah aus, als hätte er es im Griff. Und deswegen ist er gewählt worden. Und seitdem haben wir dieses Spin-Doctoring, was in den USA inzwischen dazu geführt hat, dass die meisten, Image-Doctoring in diesem Fall, Image-Doctoring, genau, dass die meisten, so sehen, Naturen und Kongressabgeordneten aussehen und wahrscheinlich auch so sind, als wenn sie sich Botox spritzen. Das sind alles so künstliche Figuren, zig Schönheits-OPs hinter sich, weil das einfach auch tatsächlich, wenn Autorität nicht zu erreichen ist, dann kann man auch mit charismatischem Auftreten und gutem Aussehen Punkte machen.
Dann muss man wenigstens so aussehen, wie das Alphamännchen vom Dienst.
Ach nee, gar nicht Alphamännchen, einfach...
Seriösität so, ja.
Seriös oder sympathisch reicht auch. Also bei Bush war es ja nicht Seriösität, sondern dieses, der Kumpel von dem Mann. Also der hat ein Freund simuliert.
Was für ein Kumpel hast du denn?
Nein, naja, für die Hillybillies. Für seine Zielgruppe.
Verstehe.
Also das muss nicht Seriösität sein. Das ist in Deutschland noch sehr darauf fokussiert, dass Politiker versuchen, Seriösität zu simulieren, in dem sie einen Anzug tragen. Aber in Amerika ist das noch eher so, dass die einfach tatsächlich versuchen, auszusehen wie irgendwelche Models, ja. Also alte Models natürlich. Aber das ist immer so ein richtig gruseliger Kulturschock, wenn man ins Ausland geht und da Nachrichten guckt und sieht, wie die Leute, die da etabliert sind, also wenn man hier Nachrichten guckt und da ist dann ein Wickelt, ja, oder irgendjemand, den man seit Jahren kennt, dann sieht der aus wie ein seriöser Sprecher und man hat sich an den Duktus gewöhnt und findet die Stimme irgendwie mal so vertrauenswürdig. Aber wenn du ins Ausland gehst, wo sich ein anderer Duktus etabliert hat, das finde ich immer super gruselig. Also gerade in Amerika, wo die so Barbie-Puppenfiguren als Vorleserinnen haben. Bei uns gibt es ja dann immer noch so im Kostüm. Aber wenn man in Amerika TV-Nachrichten guckt, das sind alles echt Barbie-Puppen, die da wegen ihres Äußeren sitzen und die auch in Diskussionen absichtlich keine sinnvollen Punkte äußern, sondern immer so dann Giggle-Giggle irgendwie für die Optik da sind. Und das ist ja antrainiert. Also es gibt Untersuchungen zu den Frauen, das sind Leute mit Hafer-Abschluss, die sind nicht blöde. Also gerade bei Fox News kann man das sehr gut sehen. Die sind nicht blöde, aber die stellen sich da blöde, weil das einfach gefordert ist. Und teilweise, was da auch in Game-Show-Moderatoren sieht, man ist auch sehr gut, wenn man sieht, was im Ausland für Leute Game-Shows moderieren und was bei uns für Leute Game-Shows moderieren. Also ein himmelweiter Unterschied. Und es ist sehr augenöffnend zu sehen, mal die Bilder abzugleichen.
Bei Glücksrad gab es...
Ja, natürlich, das waren bei uns auch so, so Schuhverkäufertypen. Aber guckt ihr mal den Amerikaner an, der Glücksrad macht. Da liegst du dich flach.
Ernsthaft?
Diese Geschichte, mit dem, dass man eher Autoritäten glaubt oder Leuten, die aussehen, wie der Kumpel von nebenan oder wie jemand, dem man so vertrauen kann, ist ja mittlerweile auch schon wieder ein Stück weit ins Gegenteil verkehrt. Also wenn du so einen typischen Versicherungsvertreter, also dir halt so in dem typischen seriösen Versicherungsvertreter oder Autofreikäufer, dem glaubst du instinktiv ja schon mal nicht mehr. Ja, der kommt schon so ja so rüber, so wie so, na ja, so.
Da hat man in den 80ern auch zum ersten Mal diesen Trend beobachten können, denn die sind immer, wie hieß der, was, Hamburg-Mandheimer oder so, diesen, keine Ahnung, wie der hieß, aber der ist halt immer im Anzug gewesen und irgendwann fingen die Spots an, da war der im Pulli, plötzlich. Und wirkte überhaupt nicht mehr seriös, sondern da haben sie halt versucht so dieses, naja, das dein Nachbar dem kann zu vertrauen, zu machen. Und also die Experimente sind durchaus alt und es ist sehr lohnend, sich das mal bewusst anzugucken.
Na die neueste Interaktion ist ja jetzt Social Media, also Werbung in Social Media.
Genau.
Ist ja de facto ja die ewige Tupperware-Party. Also...
Wer Tupperware nicht kennt, da sollten wir vielleicht kurz erklären, wie das funktioniert.
Genau, Tupperware sind eine Plastischachtlung durchaus hoher Qualität, die...
Strukturvertrieb im BW.
Ja, Strukturvertrieb, aber in der Bekanntschaft und im Freundeskreis und in der Verwandtschaft vertrieben werden. Das heißt, da werden dann so genannten Tupperware-Partys veranstaltet. Das heißt, da kommen dann irgendwie die Kumpels und Freunde zusammen, irgendwie alle bringen noch einen Salat mit und dann irgendeiner, entweder ist ein Tupperware-Vertreter eingeladen oder einer von den Mädels, die das dann veranstalten, ist dann, meistens sind es Frauen, ist dann Tupperware-Vertreterin. Und die haben dann diese Plastischachteln und dann wird halt erzählt, und hier und so, diese Plastischachteln sind super toll und dann die haben auch lauter Tricks mit irgendwie Vakuum erzeugen und den ganzen Trödelwurz. Irre teuer. Aber dann entsteht halt dieser Gruppenverkaufsdruck und dasselbe wurde auf alles Mögliche mittlerweile übertragen. Also auf Dissous.
Nicht nur Gruppen, sondern...
Botox-Partys?
Ja, es gibt Botox-Partys. Unglaublich, gibt es.
Was?
Leute treffen sich, um sich Nervengift zu spritzen.
Also ich meine, ich kenne ja, dass Leute sich treffen, um andere Gifte zu konsumieren, aber...
Also es gibt jetzt zwei Punkte. Erstens natürlich dieser Gruppendruck, aber der Kontakt zu dem Verkäufer kam über einen Freund zustande. Und das ist ein wichtiges Element, weil man einfach einen Vertrauensvorschuss genießt, wenn man von einem Freund vorgestellt wurde.
Ja und genauso ist jetzt halt, wie gesagt, wenn wir mal auf Twitter gucken oder so, wenn da irgendjemand über sein neues Telefon twittert und ich zumindest ihn nicht direkt anfollowen will, weil er auch mal was interessantes gesagt hat, dann frag ihn als erstes mal, was er dann dafür kriegt.
Hoffentlich kriegt er was dafür. Aber es gibt ja Leute, da hab ich so...
Ich hoffe, er kriegt nichts dafür, weil dann anfollowe ich ihn sofort.
Ehrlich gesagt, das finde ich noch schlimmer, wenn Leute so blöde sind, von sich aus, irgendwelche Produktwerbung zu twittern.
Wait, wait, wait. Ich glaube, wir reden von verschiedenen Sachen. Es geht schon darum, wenn jemand sagt, ich hab ein neues Telefon und ich find das geil, und du willst sozusagen dann rausfinden, hat er jetzt ein neues Telefon und findet es geil oder kriegt er gerade...
Präzise.
Ich finde das vertretbar, wenn er dafür Geld kriegt.
Nee, das finde ich überhaupt nicht.
Dann will ich dem auch nicht...
Dann hat er nichts in meiner Timeline zu suchen. Selbstverständlich nicht.
Aber dann kann ich das nachvollziehen. Aber ich finde es schlimmer, wenn Leute von sich aus brainwashed genug sind, um irgendwelche Produktwerbung...
Entschuldigung, also ich meine...
Entschuldigung, magst du mal die Apple-Blocke lesen?
Na ja, aber wenn Markus zum Beispiel über einen Game twittert, also wenn ich zum Beispiel sage, ich brauche jetzt mal wieder einen Shooter für den Winter, sollte möglichst nicht so bloody sein, sollte auf dem Mac laufen, irgendwie ordentliche Sniper-Bish-Inhalte und noch so drei, vier unrealistische Forderungen und Markus jetzt nicht total weglacht, sondern sagt, hey, guck dir doch mal das und das an, dann weiß ich, okay, das ist irgendwie in Ordnung, das kann ich mir angucken, dass jemand, der davon Ahnung hat, weil er sich die ganze Nacht beschäftigt. Wenn du jetzt plötzlich anfangen würdest und sagst, Alter, ich hab mir jetzt so einen MacBook Air gekauft, 11 Zoll, super geil. Ich sag, Fefe? Was haben sie mit dir gemacht?
Also ich find Produktwerbung immer scheiße, aber wenn jemand wenigstens dafür bezahlt wird, hat er eine Ausrede.
Nee, finde ich nicht.
Das ist was anderes, wenn du ein Journalist bist, der für seinen Lebensunterhalt...
Lass mal kurz da bleiben. Das heißt, wenn ich mit dir auf irgendeine Art und Weise im Netz öffentlich kommuniziere und ein Produkt, welcher Art auch immer gut finde, ist das schon Werbung?
Nein.
Aber darüber reden wir schon.
Nein, im Moment. Der Übergang ist sehr fließend.
Also zum Beispiel Frank Rieger.
Ich glaube, in wie lange mach ich das mein Blog? Fünf Jahre. Hab ich, glaube ich, zweimal Produkte erwähnt, mit denen ich zufrieden war. Und das, finde ich, ist eine Quote, mit der kann man arbeiten. Aber weißt du, es gibt so Blogs, die haben sich quasi darauf spezialisiert. Die ganze Zeit irgendwie nur so, ich hab das gekauft im Apple Store und das sieht jetzt schon wieder so super.
Na gut, selbst du musst dadurch kaufbauschen und was anderes.
Da brauchen wir nicht drüber reden. Aber worum es geht, ist halt die Kontaminierung des gefilterten Informationsstroms. Ich benutze ja Twitter unter anderem dafür, dass ich eine Auswahl aus diesem großen Internet bekomme, aus dem Informationsstrom des Internets, der vorgefiltert ist, eben durch die Leute, denen ich folge oder deren Blogs ich lese. Und wenn dieser Informationsstrom eben durch Werbung kontaminiert wird, weil die Leute dafür bezahlt werden oder Schnittchen bekommen oder was auch immer, dann finde ich das richtig verwerflich. Das ist ja eben kein Spam, sondern wenn es Leute sind, die sonst zum Beispiel interessante Links posten, aber dann halt anfangen, diese Positionen, die sich da erarbeitet haben.
Das ist doch immer noch Spam.
Eben, genau. Aber das ist genau der kritische Punkt, ist eben dieses Ausnutzen von Vertrauen. Darauf wollte ich hinaus. Also dass Leute das Vertrauen, was ich in sie gesetzt habe, in dem ich ihnen folge, missbrauchen, dafür, dass sie halt irgendwelchen Scheiß da reintun sollen. Und das ist halt genau, bei Politik ist es ja noch viel schlimmer. Bei Politik ist es ja so, denen muss ich ja für vier Jahre vertrauen, wenn ich sie wähle.
Nee.
Naja, also zumindest ist es so.
Nun, lass mal die Kirche im Dorf hier.
Zumindest habe ich unterhalb einer Revolution nicht viele Möglichkeiten, sie vorher zum Aufreden zu überreden. Dann ist es halt so, dass du musst dich halt für vier Jahre entscheiden und den Scheiß, den sie derzeit machen, bist du implizit mit verantwortlich. So und das ist halt so ein Ding, wo eben auch wiederum bei Medien ja genau genau das selbe Problem entsteht. Wenn ich dem nicht mehr vertrauen kann, dass was ich vorne auf der Spiegel-Online-Titelseite sehe, dass es tatsächlich eine Meldung ist, die sie nicht einfach werbartem vom Innenministerium, beziehungsweise von irgendeiner BKA-Quelle diktiert bekommen haben, sondern da tatsächlich Journalismus hintersteht, weil ich dem nicht nur vertrauen kann, denn das kreditiert sich auch alles, was möglicherweise dahinter an Vertrauenswürdigem sein könnte. Wenn ich da diesen Nershin Mushabara-Scheiß lese, der irgendwie seit Monaten und Monaten und Monaten irgendwie nur noch diese Terrorpanik-Scheiße publiziert, da kann der auch mal losgegangen sein und recherchiert haben und vielleicht wirklich was rausgefunden haben. Ich glaub's ihm einfach nicht mehr. Weil alles, was da bisher kam, ist nur noch dieser Kram, der klingt, als wurde er direkt von irgendwo einem wir brauchen mal dringend die Vorratsdatenspeicherung BKA-Fuzzi diktiert worden sein.
Da entsteht übrigens gerade eine Industrie. Das kann man auch bei der Tagesschau jetzt sehen. Die haben auch so eine Meldung gehabt. Das hat mich ja echt umgehauen, denn die haben ja mal so einen, ich will nicht sagen Vertrauensvorschuss.
Da doch, haben sie schon klar.
Aber also, ich meine, da hat man zumindest irgendwie das Gefühl gehabt, da sitzt, weißt du, die haben Korrespondenten, da sitzt eine Redaktion. Aber die tagesschau.de hat neulich so einen Artikel publiziert, ich glaube, jetzt vor drei Tagen. Da dachte ich so, was? Also der Inhalt des Artikels war, es gibt jetzt ein Hochglanzmagazin von Al-Kaida. Und da steht drin, der Terroranschlag so und so, der hat ja nur so und so viel Dollar gekostet. Und es war so völlig abstandsloser Hochglanz-Modemagazin-Niveau, irgendwie Promi-Klatsch und Tratsch-Journalismus. Und ich dachte, ach du meine Güte.
Das ist aber das Kennzeichen von genau dieser ganzen Berichterstattung über Terrorismus und alles, was damit zusammenhängt. Was ist der Abstand? Naja, ist auch, dass die, also das erfüllt halt zwei Voraussetzungen. Zum einen ängstigt das die Leute, das heißt, es führt dazu, dass es eine hohe Aufmerksamkeit genießt. Und zum anderen gibt es kaum Fakten. Es gibt da nur diese Terrorismus-Experten, die dann aus gemunkelder, gewöhnlich gut unterrichteten Kreisen, eben halt irgendwelche, meistens sind es halt eben Sicherheitsbeamte aus dem Apparat, die ein eigen Interesse haben. Die sind dann eben die Hauptquellen. Und von denen bekommen sie dann halt Sachen durchgestochen oder irgendwie erzählt. Und die sind natürlich dafür extrem offen für Manipulation. Und also, wenn ich mir so angucke, wen die Leute da, also auch Deutsche öffentlich-rechtlich, anschalten, wen die da als Terror-Experten hinsetzen, wenn man sich die Biografie anguckt, dann kann deren Expertise nur darin bestanden haben, dass sie fünf, sechs amerikanische schlechte Bücher gelesen haben.
Und sich mal einladen lassen.
Und danach dann irgendwie vielleicht noch eine Konferenz besucht haben. Und jetzt sind sie ja plötzlich Experten dafür. So. Und dann erzählen die halt irgendeinen Scheiß, der genau derselbe Mist ist, den alle anderen erzählen. So, weil irgendwie alle anderen Terror-Experten auf genau denselben Konferenzen waren, genau dieselben fünf, sechs schlechten Bücher gelesen haben und mit genau denselben Leuten vom BKA reden. Also das ist halt so ein Zyklus, wo mir mittlerweile wirklich jegliches Vertrauen fehlt, überhaupt da noch irgendwelche realistische Informationen zu bekommen.
Ich möchte da noch ein bisschen reinhauen und zwar, wo gerade das Wort...
Du bist doch ja aber das Opfer...
.Korrespondenten viel. Habt ihr euch schon mal gefragt, wenn in Indonesien eine Katastrophe ist, warum dann der Korrespondent aus Peking geschaltet wird?
Na, weil das Netz ausgedünnt wurde. Richtig.
Und wisst ihr, wo der seine Informationen herbekommt?
Na, aus der chinesischen Tagespresse wahrscheinlich.
Ne, aus seinem Fax. Da wird ihm nämlich die ausgedruckte Agentur aus Berlin gefaxt.
Aber er hat ja irgendwie ein bisschen Delay auf dem Satelliten und deswegen...
Sieht das genau aus. Ich hab's in der Tat häufiger erlebt, dass so was passiert ist, dass sozusagen natürlich ist der Typ, der in Peking sitzt. Also ja, im zeitlichen Zeifelsfall hat er sozusagen...
Den Zeitzonenfoto.
Hat er irgendwas gelesen oder gehört. Aber es ist ja oft auch so, wenn dann hier eine Sendung ist, die da zu einer Zeit stattfindet, wo irgendwie alle im Bett sind und nichts mehr kommt, dann wird halt hier einfach stumpf der Ticker, okay, gemailt. Aber es ist jetzt also nicht so weit, weil wir das am Anfang der Sendung auch da waren, sozusagen wie wichtig der Ticker eigentlich ist. So wichtig ist der Ticker. Dass der Typ sozusagen, der eigentlich von vor Ort berichten soll, auch nur das weiß, was da rauskommt.
Das ist ja echt mal geil.
Und jetzt sind wir mittlerweile so weit, dass selbst das Durchstechen von offensichtlich gezielten BKA-Informationen, also wo es offensichtlicher kann ja nicht anders sein, als dass sie da eine Quelle hatten jetzt für der Spiegel für diese, sie wollen irgendwie den Reichstag stürmen Nummer. Dass die jetzt wiederum dafür dienen soll, was der Kauder da gerade publiziert hat, die Pressefreiheit, also das bisschen Restpressefreiheit, was wir in Deutschland noch haben, also im Sinne von Freiheit zu recherchieren, auch noch einzuschränken. Weil dann sollte die Presse entweder selbst verpflichtet werden oder eben nicht mehr darüber berichten dürfen.
In der Tat.
Also man muss sich das mal auf der Zunge zergehen lassen. Wir haben hier gerade einen Terroralarm, wo schwerbeweffendete Polizisten vor dem Reichstag stehen, auf der Basis von drei Telefonanrufen an das BKA, wo man dem ein bisschen was in der Presse zu lesen war, trauen darf und ein bisschen Gemunke vom FBI, wo der BND und die CIA sagen, das wird wohl Bullshit sein. Also ich meine, wenn der BND und die CIA sagen, das wird wohl Bullshit sein, dann kann man sagen, naja, gut, möglicherweise ist da vielleicht was dran.
Also BND sind Experten für Bullshit.
Du meinst, die sehen den auch, aber wenn sie ihn... Was ja auch interessant ist, dass der Kauder gesagt hat, also das darf nicht, weil wenn mögliche Ziele publiziert werden, dann könnte das ein möglicher Anreiz sein. Und ich finde, der Schritt von dahin...
Wie sollte das ein möglicher Anreiz sein?
Das war doch seine...
Nee, die Argumentation war, wenn die Presse schreibt, irgendwie die Terroristen könnten beim Reichstag zuschlagen, dass dann erst die Terroristen auf die Idee kommen könnten, beim Reichstag zuzuschlagen.
Ein Zitat aus der Saarbrücker Zeitung. Wenn die Presse darüber berichtet, welche Orte besonders gefährdet sind, dann kann das unter Umständen ein Anreiz für Terroristen sein. Das heißt, ich impliziere jetzt einfach mal, das heißt, wenn die Presse darüber berichtet, könnte sie den Terror sozusagen Vorschub leisten. Das heißt, Journalismus ist Terrorismus.
Ja, natürlich. Okay, dann wird das eigentlich mal geklärt.
Ja, sehr gut.
Du wolltest ja sowieso irgendwie einen anderen Beruf, oder?
PR, ne?
Ach, PR, ja, stimmt. Ja, ist klar. Ja, ist richtig so.
Das ist übrigens auch ein kleiner Randonautiz noch von wegen Freunde empfehlen Produkte, wenn du mit Agenturen redest für Computerspiele, es wird grundsätzlich geduzt.
Natürlich.
Und das ist natürlich so.
Ich meine, du würdest dir auch deinen Koks nicht mit Leuten teilen, die du dich duzt, oder?
So sieht es aus. Also das Ding ist, Computerspiele werden ja von Spieljournalisten, also sozusagen die Magazine, die das nur machen, die können das tatsächlich auch sozusagen sich leisten, die Spiele zu kaufen. Das heißt, sie haben sozusagen einen richtigen Blindtest. Aber als General Interest Medium und freier Journalist als Spielertester gehst du halt hin und sagst, lieber Agentur, bitte habt ihr ein Rezensionsexemplar für mich.
Also Agenturen, die sind die Werbe...
Werbeagenturen für... Du redest selten mit den Spielefirmen direkt, sondern die haben halt eine Agentur aus der Electronic Arts, die haben eine völlig unterbesetzte PR-Redaktion, die sozusagen auch namenlos ist, wenn du da ein Spiel bestellen willst, was nochmal ein anderes Thema ist. Aber sozusagen wird da grundsätzlich geduzt und damit hast du natürlich auch ein bisschen dieses, den Freund gibt dir das Spiel und dann hat er natürlich auch diese Nachfrage. Also wie gesagt, das bleibt alles im Rahmen, aber es zielt natürlich auch darauf ab.
Verstehe, du gehörst dazu, man ist ja eine Peer-Group. Genau, so sieht's aus.
Gut, dass wir die Mechanismen hier erläutern.
Was auch lustig ist, es gibt ja immer Mitternachtsverkäufe, wenn World of Warcraft ein neues Ding rauskommt, und da fragst du dich als Journalist, ich möchte da gerne rein und natürlich möchtest du dann nicht an der Schlange stehen, weil du willst ja darüber berichten und möglicherweise in der Nacht ein Spiel spielen. Das ist total schlimm, was man da so arbeiten muss, aber so. Und das Ding ist, du bist ja natürlich als VIP da. Heißt, du kriegst dann sagen, du darfst nicht an der Schlange vorbei, sondern du kriegst auch Drinks.
Du kriegst auch ein Exemplar. Ein Schnittchen. Kriegst du ein Schnittchen?
Ja, du kriegst Schnittchen.
Das ist nämlich auch ein Punkt auf meiner Liste. Es stellt sich raus, super geil, die haben an Unis Tests gemacht, haben Leute befragt zu einem sinnlosen Laberthema, was keinen interessiert hat, absichtlich und haben dieselbe Gruppe quasi befragt. Einmal vor dem Essen, einmal nachdem sie Schnittchen gereicht haben und die Toleranz für Bullshit steigt gewaltig, wenn du gerade ein Schnittchen gekriegt hast. Dann sind die Leute gut gelaunt, haben was im Magen, haben Zeit und hören sich dein Scheiß an und sind also viel weniger auf negative Gefühle zu bringen.
Dann gibt es zum Beispiel bei der Bundesdruckerei immer, wenn sie über den Personalausweis... Immer Schnittchen natürlich. Auch wenn sie da Journalisten einladen, ich will jetzt mal gerade keinen namentlich nennen hier, die dann halt dahin kommen und gesagt bekommen, wie toll der neue Personalausweis ist. Die haben immer echt exzellente Schnittchen. Die haben ganz super Essen. Wie ist das? Haben die bei den großen Spielen, die verdienen noch richtig Geld? Machen die dann auch mal so rauschende Feste?
Ist das alles gar nicht so? Der Journalist hat mal nach Süditalien geflogen.
Das gibt es nur in der Pharma-Branche.
Und bei den Autoginalisten.
Was, echt?
Ja klar, Autoginalisten werden zu diesen Tests gefahren.
Bei Spielen ist es so, du kriegst halt ein Rezensionsexemplar, was auch nicht die geile Collector's Edition ist, sondern du kriegst die DVD in einer kleinen Plastöhle. Und wenn die so eine Mitternachts-Action haben, dann wirst du da halt sozusagen, kannst du damit hingehen. Aber es ist schon bei Spiele-Hardware ist es so, also wenn die irgendwie eine neue Gitarre auf dem Markt kriegen, dann kriegst du das für eine oder zwei Wochen zum Testen und dann wollen sie das halt wieder haben. Das lustige ist, die einzige Spiele-Hardware, die mir niemals sozusagen von der Agentur überlassen wurde, war das Skateboard von Tony Hawk und das war scheiße.
Wahrscheinlich wussten sie, dass es irgendwie die Rücktransport nicht überlebt.
Ja, das ist gut.
Oder dass es transportlich wert ist.
Ach nee, die Entsorgungskosten, die machen wir mal dezentral.
Ja, genau.
Super.
Ja, ist natürlich die Frage...
Ja, man sollte doch denken, so viel Geld... Also was war jetzt irgendwie die aktuelle Einnahme, dass sie euch da nochmal ordentlich durch die Gegend fliegen und Wein trinken?
Dazu zwei interessante Sachen. Das eine ist, ich arbeite für ein sogenanntes General Interest Medium. Ich würde sagen, ich schreibe nicht nur für die Gamer. Das heißt, ich muss mich hinten anstellen. Das hat bei Edelmann, der Agentur für Microsoft, sehr lange gedauert, bis ich herausgefunden habe, warum ich nicht auf dem ganz normalen Presseverteiler stehe. Die haben einen Presseverteiler für General Interest. Da schreiben sie einmal im Jahr, wenn sie das neue Familienspiel rausbringen. Das andere ist, dass die Spieleindustrie tatsächlich, das macht sich vor allem... Also das ist bei den großen Games nicht so, aber bei dieser Casual Games solche, die gerade sozusagen durchgeht, ist es so, die verdienen nicht an Bestandskunden. Das heißt, denen ist Berichterstattung total egal, denen ist auch Kundenbindung total egal. Woran die verdienen, ist an Neukunden. Die haben halt am Tag so und so viele Neukunden, die halt auch irgendwie in den In-Game-Shops dann für Pfennigbeträge was kaufen und machen dadurch Millionenumsätze und müssen das einfach nicht.
Verstehe, okay. Naja, also diese Geschichte mit dieser Journalistenbehandlung hat ja also diesem Erzeugen von Knappheit, dass du halt also versuchst zu sagen, naja, für dieses Spiel keine Ahnung, oder ich weiß nicht, ob es da so ist, aber bei anderen Sachen. Apple macht das jetzt zum Beispiel so, dass sie halt sagen, so wir haben nur 25 Journalisten dürfen hiermit auf diesen Event oder so. Also diese Sachen, also diese künstliche Erzeugung von Nachrichtenknappheit um ein bestimmtes Ding ist ja auch ein sehr beliebter Trick, der immer wieder gut funktioniert.
Das ist nicht nur Nachrichtenknappheit, sondern es ist auch ein anderes sehr interessantes psychologisches Experiment. Und zwar geht es da um die Aufnahmerituale bei Bruderschaften an US-Universitäten. Wer das nicht kennt, wenn man da neu beitritt, dann haben die so längliche Herabwürdigungsrituale, wo es dann darum geht, dass die irgendwie sich nackt ausziehen müssen und dann irgendwie im BH, also auch die Männer im BH irgendwie über den Campus laufen müssen und also degradierende Bullshit machen müssen, der überhaupt keinen Sinn hat. Aber wenn man das untersucht, stellt man raus, je mehr Ärger du dabei hast, einer Organisation beizutreten, desto höher bewertest du die Wichtigkeit der Organisation für dich selbst, weil du nämlich rückwirkend vor dir selbst rechtfertigen musst, warum du diesen Scheiß eigentlich gemacht hast. Und deswegen gibt es einen riesen Druck von den Leuten, die das gemacht haben, dafür zu sorgen, dass die anderen es auch machen müssen. Weil sie nämlich sagen, diese Organisation ist so wichtig, da wollen wir Leute, die das nicht über sich ergehen lassen, wollen wir gar nicht haben. Und es gibt es ja nicht nur bei diesen, also bei diesen Uni schlagenden Verbindungen gibt es das ja sowieso, aber es gibt es auch bei Polizei zum Beispiel oder bei Militärs. Die US Marines sind bekannt dafür, dass sie auch furchtbare Rituale haben, wo auch wirklich Leute zu Schaden kommen, also verwundet werden. Und dieses Phänomen ist natürlich genauso, wenn die nicht einfach jeden Journalisten reinlassen, sondern wenn du als Journalist Ärger und Aufwand damit hast, um auf deren Liste zu kommen, dann bist du danach unkritischer deren Produkte gegenüber. Und du findest dich natürlich implizit besser, als die Leute, die dich rauf gekommen sind. Wichtiger. Und hast ein Interesse daran, diesen Status beizubehalten. Und ein ähnliches Phänomen gibt es auch auf Produkt-Ebene. Da gibt es nämlich diese Special-Version, wo dann irgendwie noch eine handgemalte Karte beiliegt und ein Bullshit, den man natürlich überhaupt nicht braucht. Da geht es auch darum, künstlich Knappheit zu erzeugen. Und der Preis, also üblicherweise, also ich will nicht sagen generell doppelt so hoch wie irgendwie das normale Spiel, also aber deutlich mehr höher als die Beilagen es rechtfertigen würden. Und da geht es natürlich um die Ausnutzung desselben Effekts. Genauso übrigens wie in Flugzeugen, wenn es da die Business Class gibt, die kostet auch völlig überproportional mehr als sie wert sein müsste. Aber da geht es halt darum, wenn du die Business Class hast, dann sollst du auch sie wieder haben wollen, weil du nämlich das Gefühl hast, sie ist es wert. Und sie ist es wert, weil du viel dafür bezahlt hast.
Naja und du halt im Zweifel unter anderen Leuten bist, die viel dafür bezahlt haben.
Genau.
Ist ja dann die Kohorte. Gut, ich denke damit, wenn wir für heute mal wieder so einigermaßen durch, die Aufgabe an unsere Hörer lautet, guckt euch mal den Terrorpanik-Scheiß der nächsten Tage in Ruhe an und versucht mal daran, die Mechanismen, die wir diese Sendung besprochen haben, so ein bisschen wiederzufinden.
Zwei Worte wollte ich noch sagen. Zwei Worte wollte ich noch sagen. Ältesten Rat und Wirtschaftsweise.
Ja, Autoritätskacke.
Genau, überlegt euch mal, warum klingt es so, als wenn es eine Autorität wäre? Wer ist es eigentlich? Warum ist es eigentlich mehr als einer? Wieso ist es nicht einfach Professor so und so? Sondern hier ist auch noch ein Konsens. Das heißt, es ist auch noch eine Herde, die man folgen kann. So diese Art von Effekt, die ist um uns rum überall und ihr müsst ja mal drauf achten. Denn das ist ein Problem, wenn man es einfach unkritisch wahrnimmt. Versucht mal, solche Dinge zu sehen, wenn sie euch begegnen. Und fragt euch, warum das eigentlich alles so ist, wie es jetzt ist.
Ja, das Letzte war ja gerade die schwerbeweffneten Polizisten, die überall rumstehen.
Genau, das wollte ich noch erzählen. Also das Berliner Stadtbild ist gerade geprägt von diesen Maschinenpistolen tragenden Bundespolizeisonderkohorten. Und auf dem Weg hier zu der Aufnahme habe ich mir gedacht, frag doch mal einen, wie ihr eigentlich persönlich zu diesem Terroralarm steht. Also eigentlich habe ich gedacht, ich gehe jetzt zum Bahnhof, weil es heißt, die stehen auf vielen Bahnhöfen, insbesondere auch auf meinem. Und dann habe ich gedacht, da gehst du mal hin und fragst hin. Und ich stellte fest, die stehen gar nicht an meinem Gleis. Ja, mein Gleis war das Gleis statt einwärts in Richtung Bundestag. Da stehen die morgens, stellt sich heraus. Also die Leute stehen nicht für uns da, sondern die stehen für die Leute da, die morgens zum Bundestag gehen und abends vom Bundestag kommen. Also das heißt, die Helfershelfer der Abgeordneten. Die stehen da auch nicht wegen der Sicherheit, sondern die stehen nicht wegen der Sicherheit, sondern damit sie gesehen werden. Genau, so sieht das aus.
Ach, das hatte Demisier gemeint, als er sagte, jetzt nicht auf Überstunden machen, nicht auf Überstunden achten, sondern bitte Pflicht erfüllen.
Genau, es geht ja schließlich darum, dass wir uns gesehen haben.
Verstehe, verstehe.
Ja, in diesem Sinne. Ansonsten nochmal herzlichen Dank für die zahlreichen Fletterspenden, die es übrigens ermöglicht haben, dass wir jetzt mit vier Headset hier operieren können. Das heißt so auch unsere Gäste.
Darf ich an dieser Stelle kurz sagen, dass ich neidisch bin?
Obwohl Monoxid ist neidisch auf unser Headset. Ja, also wir haben jetzt so bis jetzt ein einigermaßen taugliches Podcasting Setup, wofür wir weitere Fletterspenden verwenden, wenn wir uns noch überlegen. Es gab da ein paar interessante Vorschläge, aber...
Vielleicht kann man dir auch noch einen Pop-Schutz kaufen?
Na, wir kaufen erstmal einen. Mann ey, musst du eigentlich immer hier immer immer immer Salz auf die Wunde noch. Immer aufs Schlimme. Diese Radioleute...
Ich bin ja gleich weg.
Der Kopfhörer bleibt hier.
Mist. Sie sind nummeriert und abgezählt. Ja, also wie gesagt, nochmal vielen Dank fürs Flettern. Vielen Dank an Abo Monoxid für die heutige Radio-Sendungsbeteiligung.
Ja, ich bin schon mal auf meinen nächsten Beitrag. Wahrscheinlich werden sie da sitzen und denken so, welche Schranke baust du jetzt ein? Wie machst du es am besten?
Genau. Profis bei der Arbeit. Insofern vielen Dank.
Du brauchst mehr Captures. Wer bei dir einen account einrichten will, der kriegt nicht einen Capture, sondern der muss ein Lied nachsingen.
Find ich eine gute Idee. Fefe fängt an.
Gut, bevor es hier noch in Gesinge ausartet, hören wir mal auf und vielen Dank.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Tschüss.